welcome to this comprehensive course on
open AIS assistance API which allows
developers to build powerful AI
assistance capable of performing a
variety of tasks this course covers
essential topics like integrating the
API for advanced functionalities
leveraging its knowledge retrieval and
code interpretation capabilities and
understanding the fundamentals of large
language models through Hands-On
projects with streamlet and real world
examples you'll gain practical skills to
build respon responsive AI enhanced
applications by the end you'll be able
to use the assistance API to transform
your web apps into Dynamic smart
platforms hello and welcome to this
course my name is Paulo deson I am a
software engineer so I teach people how
to become software Engineers developers
and build applications and I've also
taught over 250,000 students on various
skills from programming build apps AI as
well as Cloud engineering so welcome to
this course the next question is what is
it that you're going to be learning in
this course well in this course you're
going to be learning about the assistant
API essentially you're going to learn
about functional calls you're going to
learn about retrieval mechanisms and of
course you're going to be building a lot
of stuff going through this course
because that is how I like to introduce
certain Concepts to my students so
that's part of the what you're going to
be expecting in this course and of
course I'll be talking about large
language models embeddings and all these
things that relate to AI specifically
okay now let's talk about the
prerequisites for this course so I
expect you to at least have the basics
of programming of course I don't expect
to be an expert or anything as long as
you have some fundamentals of
programming be it on JavaScript or any
other modernish programming language you
should be fine going uh through this
course and one thing to keep in mind is
that unfortunately this is not a
one-on-one programming course I'm not
going to teach you how to progam program
rather I'll focus on the big picture
idea of assistance API and large
language models so we're going to be
using python in this course so if you've
never used python you don't even know
what python is that's okay that's not
the main thing here the main thing is
that I want you to understand how this
technology how assistance API and how
large language models how AI based
applications are built that is the main
goal here so don't worry you'll be fine
as long as you want to learn and you
follow along what I'm going to be doing
the other thing also remember that
you'll have access to all of that code
in the description below okay now let's
go ahead and look into python setup and
essentially the environment setup so
that you can follow along in this course
now keep in mind if you already have
python set up on your machine and you
have Visual Studio code or any other
code editor that you use obviously you
don't have to follow along because this
is you have all that right so if you
don't have that then I'm going to show
you right now what you need to do what
you need to install on your machine that
way you able to follow along in this
course now the best place I found online
where you are able to go through
tutorials on how to set up python
specifically on your machine whether
it's Windows Mac Linux and so forth is
this link here uh which I'm going to
show you right now let's go ahead and
take a look all right so if you go to
this link here which is kingstar docomo
base install python this does everything
that you will ever need or at least has
all of the instructions you need to
install python if you don't have python
installed on your machine okay so just
go ahead and follow exactly what they
have here and they even tell you what is
python which is kind of nice and all the
things that you need okay so just follow
along and the great thing is that you
can go through these different links
here so how to install python in Windows
if you're on Windows click here that
will take you to this setup and how to
install python on mic OS that will take
you through this whole all setup that
you need to go through and of course if
you're very special and are on Linux go
ahead and click here and just follow the
instruction so it's really
straightforward I don't see any value in
me going through all of this with you so
go ahead and get that setup if you don't
have python setup on your machine and
we'll go from there so the next thing we
will need is an IDE an integrated
development environment I use Visual
Studio code which is what I'm going to
be using in this course so if you have
something else that you use that's
totally fine go with that but go ahead
and download that if you don't have it
so it's very simple going to go to
visual studio
code and depending on your machine for
me I'm on Mac it just goes straight to
download Mac universal you can click
here and you can see that we have mac o
universal window Linux and all of this
okay so depending on your situation just
go ahead and download the ver version
the latest version of vs code and you
should be ready to go okay now because
of the nature of what we're going to be
learning in this course which is open AI
assistance API you will need to have an
open AI account that is very important
for obvious reasons and so particularly
what you need to do is you need to go
ahead and create in this case have an
API key because that's what will allow
us to use the assistance API and and
various things we can do with open Ai
apis and so forth so that is very
important so let me show you real quick
here so if you type in
open.com as you see here make this a
little bit larger you'll be able to say
log in so click here if you don't have
an open eye account you can go ahead and
say sign up if you already have one you
can just put your email and go ahead and
sign in also you can go ahead and say
continue with Google with Microsoft
account or with Apple so I already have
an account but in this case you can go
ahead and sign up okay so I'm going to
say continue with Google I think you can
also go that route to create an account
and gives you this opportunity here to
choose between going to char or going to
API we want to go to API and this is
what's going to open so this is will
take us to this main view here so
there's a lot of things a lot of
capabilities uh get started and all that
what do we really want to go to is to go
to assistance API which actually we're
going to do that later but what we want
right now is to go to API keys so click
here on API Keys you can see that I have
one API key which I created a little bit
ago so go ahead and say create an API
key and you can name
this
assist API Das key you can name whatever
you want and that API key click there to
create this API key and then what you
need to do is copy this API Key by
clicking here and save this API key for
later in this course once we get started
coding into all these things so it's
very important to not to share this with
anyone in fact after I've created this
I'm going to delete this so that way you
can't use it okay so save it in a very
safe place that way you don't lose it
okay make sure that once you close that
window just like I said there's no other
way for you to access it to get it again
so that was that's why I wanted you to
save it okay but you can create as many
secret keys as you need so if you for
some reason didn't copy that you can go
ahead and create a new one and go from
there so that should be it about setting
up your API environment understanding
what we're going to be doing in this
course as well as having your API Keys
set up or created for us to be able to
use that in this course okay so now
let's go ahead and look at what is this
thing called assistance API the
assistance API is a tool built by the
opening I folks that allows developers
to easily craft and build AI based
applications that Leverage The Open AI
environment the open AI platform per se
so the thing to understand about the
assistance API is that it's not its own
entity per se although it is but it is
attached or extends in this case what we
know the open AI API which includes all
of the tools and models that power chbt
and many other underlining
infrastructure of the open AI
environment so that is the important
distinction here is that when we talk
about the assistance API it extends what
already is there in this case the open
AI API and so it makes it easier for us
to build AI Tools in this case AI
assistance that we can use in our
applications so essentially allows us
gives us this platform this framework
this libraries to quickly use these
tools to build any application AI based
application that we would want to build
without having to know too much about
the underlining obstruction of how
things actually work so essentially we
can go ahead and create an assistant and
use the API so that we can connect that
assistant in our application and use
that assistant that has the capability
of connecting with the open AI apis
essentially now the next thing we need
to look at is for this assistance API
what is the problem that it solves now
the thing to understand is that building
applications in general later alone
building AI based applications uh it's a
very hard task for developers because
it's very complex there are usually a
lot of moving parts that a developer
needs to focus on developers need to
manage in this case certain
infrastructures they need to keep in
mind how the data is being used Which
models are needed to use in this case to
power their applications they have to
learn how to craft the best prompts
possible in order to communicate with
this large language model
and they also need to understand or keep
track of the application State
understand about embeddings which is
something totally different but it's
part of this realm of AI and large
language models and understand the
storage mechanism right how do we upload
files how does the large language model
use those files to allow us to tap into
the main knowledge but also those files
retrieval those files knowledge but also
retrieve information from those files
and so many things right so this is not
easy it's a very complex thing to carry
as a developer this poses a problem for
developers because now developers
instead of focusing on building the
actual application now they're focusing
on how to stitch all these pieces
together to make this work so the
benefit of using the assistance API is
that is that all of this complexity all
of these things that developers need to
know know or to deal with it's
abstracted out which means they don't
have to deal with it anymore because now
the assistance API the back end of
everything is taken care of all we need
to do as developers now is to focus on
what matter which is build Our
obligation so the assistance API already
has all the things that we need as
developers but we don't need to think
about them because it abstracts out all
of that work so one thing to keep in
mind is that when we talk about large
language models is that they by
themselves they don't have state which
means they don't save a context of a
conversation per se now with the
assistance API we don't have the problem
because there is this thing called
persistent threading for ongoing
conversation what this means is now
we're able to save messages and the
context of that messages that way let's
say if you're creating a bot um you
don't have to yourself save that context
so that then when you ask a certain
question that the bot needs to know
about the previous conversation the bot
will actually know what it's referring
to because it has a context okay that's
huge because now we don't have to worry
about that the assistance API has that
built in and also we have the retrieval
mechanisms for digging through data so
what this means is that we can upload
files for the models to use for
additional knowledge base so you can
upload files about something let's say
about cryptocurrency so now that piece
of knowledge is added to the main base
knowledge right that comes with the
large language model that way you can
converse with the large language model
in addition to the knowledge that we
just added by uploading certain files
documents and so forth so now we have a
more flexible and more knowledgeable if
I may say large language model because
we are aiding it with retrieval
mechanisms it also has code interpreters
so it actually writes can analyze code
and do all sort of things which is
amazing as you will see okay one of the
biggest things that we now get with
assistance API is that we can actually
do function calling what that means is
that when our assistant is solving a
problem we ask a question the assistant
will be able to call a function that we
specify that will be used as a tool to
go and fetch certain data that that the
large language model needs to solve a
certain problem and that is huge because
now in addition to uploading file for
retrieval mechanisms and so forth we can
also add more tools by adding these
functions that go serve as agents that
can go and do something else and bring
back the results which are going to be
used by the large language model in this
case the open AI apat per se or the
assistant right to solve the problem or
to answer accurately what you are asking
it for that's pretty awesome
mind-blowing let me show you the diagram
here real quick so you can see visually
the assistant API benefits so if you
look at this diagram here right the
assistants can go ahead and call the
openi models right to uh tune their
personality in this case their
capabilities also these assistants can
also access multiple tools and parallel
so now it's sort of having these agents
that can go and do stuff and bring back
the results so that we can help the
assistant to be a better assistance
right so in this case here these are
tools the tools that we have here we
talked about the code and code
interpreter we have the knowledge
retrieval right files and documents we
can pass upload so that our assistant is
more knowledgeable about certain topic
as well function calling now the great
thing about function calling is that we
can create it's a way for us to create
our own tools on top of the tools that
the assistant already has access to such
as the code interpreter knowledge
retrieval and so forth so now with this
we can create our own tools right our
own functions that go for instance and
fetch the current situation in Bulgaria
or go and fetch go and fetch some sort
of data in the database somewhere you
get the idea and along with everything
that I said we have these persistent
threads the threads we'll talk about in
a second here allows us to have these
messages that we are saving or are being
saved in our conversation and so those
are saved for context which is H huge
because remember all large language
models they don't have a concept of
saving history per se so they're
stateless so they don't have a way of
saving the context which is problematic
when we want to refer to a certain
concept that was talked about if they
don't not they're not saving that
history then it wouldn't know what
you're referring to so context is very
important and that is all given with the
assistance API okay and of course we can
access files in several formats but this
is diagram I wanted to show you about
the benefits of the assistance API now
most like of course you've heard of the
chat completion API which is the one
that you've been using if you were using
the open AI API right so you just send
messages and you receive response and
it's very useful because the completion
API it goes straight to the open AI
models and ask questions and the large
language models and of course the
knowledge base but the thing here is
that this knowledge base is knowledge
base that is already there there's no
addition meaning if you were to ask
certain questions about something that
was done or happened after September 20
after September 2023 I believe right
anything that was done after that then
the large this large language model here
wouldn't have that knowledge base so it
would just say I don't know because the
completion API is just a way for us to
get direct response okay that is the
difference here between the chat
completion API which is useful with the
assistance API gu as I have discussed
earlier okay so let's look at this
General comparison uh so we can see the
differences between the assistance API
and the chat completions API okay this
just to have some sort of an idea an
overall idea so you can see here the
aspect column and the assistance API the
chat completion API so for assistance
API initial setup you have to create an
assistant with Define capabilities which
we'll see in a little bit for chat
completion of course there's there's
nothing for you to set up you just call
the API and get the results the answers
and so forth for the assistance API we
have to initiate and manage in this case
a thread for ongoing conversation we'll
talk about what a threat is and all that
stuff in a little bit and for the chat
completion of course we have none of
that so this is just to show you the
differences between the assistance API
and the chat completions API and you can
go down here to complexity so more
complex setup of course for the
assistance API and it's simpler of
course for the Chad completions API okay
so no need to memorize this this is just
something you can take a screenshot of
and then go ahead and you know just take
a look to see the differences between
the assistance API and the chat
completions API okay and there you have
it all right so we just finished looking
at the benefits of the assistance API
and how it works and how it facilitates
our lives as developers so that we can
focus on actually building those AI
based tools right instead of worrying
about the underlying infrastructure
things that we would have to do if we
didn't have assistance so now let's look
at the assistance API the building
blocks because we talked a lot about the
underlining infrastructure how it works
to benefits let's go ahead and look
inside and see what are the building
blocks of an assistant all right so here
is a diagram I like having diagrams
because it hopefully helps you
conceptualize these ideas the assistance
API has about four main building blocks
so so first you see that we can have in
this case an assistant so the assistant
itself is in this case The Entity the
thing per se that we actually build
which will then use to help us get
information about certain topic and so
in this case here we could have an
example an assistant who is a travel
agent bot that we can use so that is the
first component and the second component
of second building block is what we call
threads a thread is where all of the
messages that occur between the
assistant and the user because that is
the whole idea all those messages are
tracked here in the thread so in this
case here a users may have a message and
say hey what is the cost for an extra
day in Paris okay so that is a message
that is going to be on a thread which
the assistant will have access to as
well as the user and then the assistance
message would be the cost is
12,890 for instance right but then you
will ask okay okay there is the
assistant's message but how does the
assistant know well the whole process
has to go through the other piece here
the other building block which is the
Run entity so the Run entity needs to
have a few things for it to be able to
run those queries those questions
essentially evaluate what's going on so
there is this dialogue per se that is
happening so in this case here the run
as you can see here we have has to have
access to the assist
in this case you will see later it's
just going to be an ID and also has to
be have access or has to have a
reference to the thread because that's
where all the messages are so in this
case here the assistant is going to be
our travel agent
bot and the thread is trip to Paris for
instance and then inside of this run the
Run can be triggered to then run
different steps to get to that
conclusion to get to the result what
would happen is if you look at all of
this we have in this case the assistant
the number one building block we have
thread that is the number two building
block inside of the thread that's we
have the message so messages or message
that's the number three building block
and number four is the actual run
entity okay and so how would all this
work well we have the assistance and
inside of the assistant we have and then
we have the thread we have a message
from the user what is the cost for an
extra day in Paris that is going to be
sent to run which will have the
assistant ID as well as the thread ID
because it needs to know where to pull
those messages that are coming in from
right and then it's going to go through
a process steps number one use code
interpreter if that's what needed to
calculate things and then is going to go
ahead and create a message and if need B
this is the beauty is going to be able
to go and call any other tool that may
be needed in order to get the correct
response and the response is going to be
as a message which is going to be
returned back again to our thread does
it make sense so the thread is where all
the action really is being dumped into
the history per se right and there we go
and now the thread will have the
assistance message because all the steps
are done we have the response and goes
back as a message assistance message
which then we can use that to show in
our application these are the assistance
API building blocks that's very
important here because it can be a
little bit tricky at first to really
conceptualize the idea the assistant
itself needs thread a thread that's
where all the messages go just think of
a bucket of messages right and then the
entity run here this is where the
running of things to go and fetch things
go through the steps this is where it
happened the Run needs to have reference
to the assistant because needs to know
who is this assistant because remember
the assistant will have all of the
specifications that it needs so it knows
what it specializes in in this case is a
travel agent bot so the Run needs to
have a piece in this case reference to
these assistant so when it goes and
starts running the steps it knows what
knowledge base it needs as well as other
tools to indeed create those message
back so the assistance messages are all
here so that we can then use those
messages to show in our applications so
forth all right so very simple but can
be complex to wrap your head around
understand and conceptualize these
building blocks then what's coming next
is not going to be too complicated okay
so rewatch this part if you need to but
I think you should be good so what we'll
do next is we're going to go in the
dashboard in the playground and look at
create creating an assistant manually
and later of course we're going to do
that using Code okay let's go ahead and
do that so now let's go and log in into
the open AI dashboard so you should have
an account and everything now when you
log in this is more or less what you're
going to be seeing so what we want to do
is you want to hover over here if you
don't see that so you click here this is
what you're going to be seeing going to
hover over and we're going to go to
assistance but this is where we need to
go so click here and sometimes takes
some time looks like uh incorrect let's
go ahead and refresh
this okay there we go so today we've
been having some issues but just refresh
if you're having some issues okay so
once you here let's go ahead and create
our first assistant so we can go ahead
and say create here or from here doesn't
matter going and create and first thing
we need to do is to add a name so let's
say this is going to
be personal trainer as such and then we
need to pass or add the instructions so
because it's an assistance we need to
say okay you are X Y and Z you're
knowledgeable in this area and so forth
okay I have the instructions here so I'm
just going to paste it in here and I'm
going to click here to make it a little
bit larger so this says you are the best
personal trainer and nutritionist who
knows how to get clients to build lean
muscles you've trained High Caliber
athletes and movie stars because that is
exact what we are all are striving to be
okay so there we go so these are the
instructions of course you will want to
put as many instructions as a prompt
really as you need for your assistance
so if specify exactly what you want your
assistance to help you with okay I'm
going to go back and next we're going to
choose the model right openi model that
we're going to be using there are a few
and as a recording of this video we have
gpg for preview and of course these
numbers will change depending on when
you're going to be watching this video
okay but just imagine just remember that
the concepts of how this worked that's
what really matters instead of things
that may change here okay so I'm just
going to go ahead and use the jpt 3.5
turo that should be fine for now and
it's a little bit cheaper as well so I'm
going to you are more you are more than
welcome to go to the higher so I'm going
to just use that one really that's fine
and then we have the tools we talked
about the tools so these allow us to
attach certain things that they we want
this assistance to be able to do if it
doesn't already have those tools right
so we have here retrieval we have the
code interpreter and we can add
functions as well okay so we don't need
anything I'm just going to go ahead and
toggle the code interpreter just because
why not okay and anything else we can
just live as is and I'm going to say
save as such so now the assistant was
created and if I get rid of this and get
rid of that and we can see that we do
have our personal trainer so there is
the instructions and the ID so this is
very important because remember the
diagram I was showing you earlier was
that um when things start running when
we have that fourth component or
building block which is the run it needs
to know this personal trainer or in this
case the assistant so this is an ID that
will be used internally later we're
going to be able to generate or create a
system using Code which I'm going to
show you but I just want to give you an
overview right now so very important
these IDs are going to be used and from
here you can see we can go and say test
so if you click here this will open a
different tab as you see here and then
you can test it out to see if this
actually works for instance you can
enter a message remember this is the
message in this case will be the user
message if I show you exactly these
assistance API building blocks this is
where we've set up so we have the
assistant which is in this case we said
it's travel agent bot but in this case
is our trainer personal trainer and we
have thread which we haven't created yet
hasn't been created but we will create
all of this is going to be created in
the back end once we start running
things and then we have the messages
which is now a user message is exactly
what we pass here okay so say I want to
build
muscles what foods should I eat I'm
going to go and say run haha run what
you think it's supposed to do well
what's going to happen now when we run
first of all that message the moment we
say run the message will be added to
thread Aha and you can see it even says
thread here right so the thread right
now is empty if I say run it's going to
go ahead and add that message and the
instructions is showing here and the
there's a lot of things that happening
here so let me go ahead and go through
everything I'm going to just make this
probably can't make that smaller that's
okay and one thing you see here this is
the thread and each thread that is
created because it is indeed a simple
message right and each thread that is
created has also an ID this will make
sense later so you can see here um we
have all the information so the thread
is where all the messages are going to
be in from this case our user the
question that we ask as well as when we
run and come back we should have the
personal trainer the message as well
just like what I showed you here this
run went ahead and pulled in the
assistant ID internally and then the
thread ID internally and then went
through the steps and sped out the
assistance message which now we can see
here is the message right this is the
assistant say personal trainer that's
the name of our assistant and says to
build muscles lean muscles that is it's
important to focus on balanced diet that
includes blah blah blah protein rich
foods whole grains fruits and vegetables
healthy fats dairy products and all this
great stuff and even gives us a little
recommendation here and note it's
important to consult with healthc care
professional and all that great stuff
very cool this is what's happening right
essentially goes back to what I showed
you earlier going back here you can also
see that we have logs now this is really
cool because it allows us to look at
exactly what happens so you can see here
we can hide the logs we don't want to
hide the logs right now because I want
to show you something so for our logs
here look at what happened the moment we
said run what happens that a thread was
created indeed because we need a thread
where all the messages are going to be
in just like again aha what I showed you
here okay okayy this is this is good
okay so if we open here you can see
exactly what happens so the thread was
created and it we have a response which
is indeed the thread ID and this ID here
is exactly the same as this this is the
thread ID that was created okay and we
have other some other metadata that's
okay and then we added a message to that
thread the message was the one that we
wrote here in fact you can see all that
happens here on the thread visually it
is what being shown here as a log but I
want you to understand this so you know
where things are in case when things
don't work you understand where to find
things okay so we have our add message
here the message was added the role is
user because I am a user in this case
because I enter the message here right
so going back it is this message here
which is going to be sent to run very
good so that
happens let me go ahead and close this
we added message and then we run the
thread right it just did a post request
aha it has to have the assistant ID why
did I tell you because if you look at
this diagram here first it said
assistant the name but internally it has
to have the actual ID as well as the
thread ID which is exactly what's
happening in the back end if I close
this thread here let's see you can see
that has the response and the response
each response has of course an ID the
object is run and when it was created
the assistant ID as well as the thread
ID voila and all of this other metadata
as well as the model that was used the
instructions all of that was sent along
in the response okay in the thread and
then of course get runs status because
when we hit run when hit run what
happens at the back end things are
happening meaning these steps are going
to go do you see maybe it has to use the
code interpreter create a message and do
all these other things it's not until
all these steps are done which means an
answer a message in this case an answer
from our run okay the our assistant in
this case uh it's not until then once
that is done that the message is
actually created and sent back so all of
that is happening here all right this is
the log and run step let's see what
happens first it has this object here
this data if I open this data here and
keep opening it has the ID the object
right these are the steps right in fact
that's that's ex that's exactly what I'm
showing you there's the status and this
is the steps going through the whole
process of creating crafting this
message for the assistant message which
is going to be sent and then we can see
the
results all right let's continue so you
can see it has a Json here response it
comes in as list an object list and we
have the data field which has an ID the
object thread step a run step when was
created and all the great stuff and
continue the other
step and as many steps as possible and
then the status run status to tell us
whether the running is over everything
is set up now we have the response the
message which can be passed back to the
assistant right so that we can then see
let's see continue completed you can see
here that the status now is completed
which mean all is good we should have a
formulated uh message okay if I go to
tools you can see what tools were used
code interpreter right in this case even
though it wasn't really needed but it's
okay and then get
runs you can see now it returns
data which has an ID has an
object and the status and everything and
then we go to the message response now
comes in as object list and data there
and you can see now we have the ID the
thread message okay the first one there
and then this is for the assistant aha
if you open here you will see that
assistant will should have let me click
here to
open aha there we go and there we go we
have the the actual value which is
exactly this what we see here says to
build muscles all in muscles all of that
information which weed back so the
assistant in this case went through this
whole process that I showed you earlier
and the return the assistant message in
this case back to our thread which then
we can see in this case we're able to
see that the information the message is
here so this is a very good
representation of the assistance in all
the building blocks but this is real
cool the log is because it sees we can
actually see all the whole process of
what's happening so we understand
exactly what's happening so it's not
this Mystery Box per se uh what you've
learned here is that to create an
assistant here manually you have to
easily just go to the assistant
API or playground ideas and just hit
create and you have to pass the name of
your assistant as well as the
instructions right so specify what do
you want your assistant to be good at or
to what knowledge these assistants has
to have right what they're going to help
you with and then of course that will
generate the
ID as you see here and of course as you
create a assistance you have to of
course as you as I showed you you have
to make sure that you attach the right
model and the tools that you want to
attach to so what I want you to do is to
create for instance a code assistant
okay so essentially uh come up with
instructions for for an assistant that
can help you with code issues right you
can say you are a very helpful Java
developer assistant blah blah blah
you're knowledgeable about the basic of
java intermediate and advanced and so
you help developers to do pair
programming whatever it is so that and
test it out and see if it works and make
sure because it's code based make sure
of course in this case you really would
need to have this code interpreter
because then you can paste in as a
message a user message a pie of code and
ask the assistant if this code will
compile if there's something you can do
they can do to improve it and so forth
so you have some ideas on how this works
okay do that and save changes and create
the assistant and then test it out and
see if it works all right go ahead and
do that and I'll see you next all right
so now we're going to actually do the
same thing we did before but in code
which is very exciting the first thing
we need to do is let's go back to our
playground here assistance playground
login and everything and I hope you were
able to do that little exercise earlier
if not well what can I
say all right so what we'll do here is
we're going to do the same thing but
we're going to be using code right so
I'm going to go ahead and delete this
yes I know it's very sad but it got to
go okay now it's empty so we're going to
do all that using Code so you should
have Visual Studio code installed or any
other rde that you may use that's fine
and it should also have python
everything set up so everything should
be good right so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to create a new folder
for our project so
personal trainer as
such going to CD to our personal should
be personal but Persona that's fine
too okay so it's empty there so I'm
going to say I'm going to say code to
open this exact here just going to going
to close that one and then there we go
so we don't have much going on here so
I'm going to go ahead and create a new
file let's call this
main.py there we go and also I'm going
to go ahead and create in this case
requirements.txt
requirements txt such this is where
we're going to put all of our
dependencies and libraries that we need
for our Python and for our project I
should say and next what I'm going to do
let's go ahead and create create a file
this is going to be our environment
variable file so EnV this is where we're
going to put our environment variable so
the idea is we're going to have our open
AI environment variable let me close
this down like that and we're going to
put your open AI key remember that key
that I showed you earlier so essentially
you're going to come here and go to API
keys and if you don't have an API key go
ahead and create one just like I showed
earlier and take that key and that's
what we're going to put inside this here
okay so go ahead and do that and for
requirements here I'm actually going to
pass in a few ones I'm going to say
python. EnV and I also need open AI
package like that very good so that's
inside of our requirements.txt I'm going
to create another file here called thatg
ignore so that's for me to hide a few
things once I push this to the
repository GitHub repository so that you
don't have things that you don't need
okay so in this case here I'm going to
make sure that our git it's going to
bypass the environmental variable file
so that it's not pushed I'm going to
create a python environment that way we
can run pip install to install
everything in this environment specific
for this project to do so uh remember
I'm on Mac here here
Python 3 and then it's going to be I'm
going to say Das m v
andv as such and then the name of the
environment so I'm going to just say my
EnV like that and what will happen now
is just going to go ahead and create I'm
going to say yes because you notice a
new environment has been created say yes
going to use that and you will see now
we have this my EnV uh with binaries
include libraries and everything this is
our python environment that we can use
then to activate so to activate it I'm
going to say
Source my EnV and then I'm going to go
to Binary and then activate hit enter
you can see now my EnV is environment is
activate so that's really good which
means then I can say
pip install d r and pass the
requirements that text which has all of
these dependencies or or packages or
libraries that we need so I'm going to
hit enter so he's going to go ahead
ahead and get all that information for
us okay so all the packages have been
downloaded that's really good let me
just clear all out of this and then now
if you look at my M of course I'm going
to go to binaries you can see that we
have Envy we have opening I which is
exactly what we added very good so we
should have everything set up now I'm
going to get rid of this so let's go
ahead and do some importing here so I'm
going to import open AI library and I'm
going to set up the m so that we are
able to get the environment variables
and do all the great stuff so I have all
that information here just going to copy
that and paste in here okay important
findm load an M
Fromm package all
right and I'm going to call this load M
there so that it all set up and then I'm
going to create a client here which I'm
going to be using the client is going to
be open ai. open AI as
such okay and now now with this client
we're going to be able to call the openi
API assistant and anything else that we
want because we have created that now
you could have also done something like
this open AI right and then say API key
and then go to os. environment. get and
pass the open AI key which is the key in
this case the value that we put inside
of our environment variable okay so
that's another way to do that but since
I'm loading all the environment variable
this to work just say client open ey.
open Ai and also if you want you can
pass the open AI key directly from here
but it seems to work just like this uh
because it gets all the environment
varable if not just go ahead and add the
openi key directly here or just like
what I showed you uh let me just do that
again I'm going to put it here I'm going
to leave it there all like that okay
whatever works for you go ahead and do
that or the other way too I'm going to
put it all here there's another way you
could have done said client open AI just
like I said pass the API key and go
ahead into the custom environment
variable if you change the names okay
but if you are using open AI _ aior key
then this should just work as it is all
right I'm going to leave that there just
in case you need that all right very
good so next what I'm going to do let's
go ahead and say model this is just a
variable that we're going to be using
and the model we're going to be using
it's going to be gpt3 for turbo and I'm
going to put it here for now okay now we
may change this you may want to use GPT
for preview depending on situations but
so far so good okay so now that we have
everything set up let's see how can we
create in this case a an assistant right
in this case we're going to create the
trainer the personal trainer assistance
very simple all we do I'm going to just
put here all we do really is just say
the assistant I'm going say
personal and then I'm going to use our
client right which is which has
instantiated our open AI there and say
client and it's going to go to Beta
remember that because as a recording of
this video the assistance API it's
actually in beta which means they're
still working on it and so maybe by the
time you watch this video you watch this
course maybe this you won't need to say
beta which will be great so just keep
that in mind for now we just have to go
to Beta and then we go to assistance and
once we get to assistance we go ahead
and say create very conveniently and
then we can pass certain parameters here
okay so what parameters do we pass here
well first of all we need to pass the
name that we want to name our personal
assistant in this case I'm going to call
this personal trainer as such and then
we pass instructions which are very very
important as you remember and I'm going
to pass the instructions here real quick
so these are the same instructions that
we used before so you are the best
personal trainer nutritionist and you've
trained High Caliber athletes and movie
stars okay there we go we have all of
that
information let me get rid of that don't
know where that came from there we go
all right and the next thing we need to
pass here is the actual model because we
need to remember this is the same thing
we've done uh manually so now we are
passing the model that we're going to be
using or the assistant it's going to be
relying on and it's going to be the
model that we pass here just put in this
variable so it's easier to change in one
place so just like that we created our
assistant and can go ahead and say print
in this case I'm going to say personal
trainer. ID right this will give us the
actual ID of this personal trainer
assistant that we just created okay and
I'm going to go and comment that out for
now the next thing we need to do is to
create yes the thread because this is
where
all of the messages as you know uh will
be so to create a thread again you see
that's very easy I'm going to say thread
and use client again beta and I'm going
to go ahead and say threads and.
create again for our thread we need to
pass a few thing now the cool thing here
is that for our thread we passed
messages which is going to be a list so
this messages here I'm going to pass an
object in this case going to start with
the role okay and the role is going to
be
user and for the user in this case the
content is going to be what well I'm
going to just put something I'm going to
say how do I get
started
working
out to
lose fat and build muscles something
like this so this will be the first
message it's going to be sent for as the
user okay we could have created a thread
with no message at all and then add
those messages later but we can go ahead
and add a message a user message right
away as well okay I'm going to go ahead
and
print actually let's call This
Thread ID and get that thread ID so just
thread. ID okay because those are needed
and I can go ahead and
print thread ID let's say so we see and
I can do the same thing here
assistant ID and personal. ID like that
and then here I can just go ahead and
when we need just going to go like that
very good so now that we have these two
things what will happen now if we run
this well we are going to be able to
create an assistant right and also in
this case create a threat
and get those IDs which you will see in
a second here so let's go ahead and run
this real quick and see if this work all
right so I know my environment is active
so I'm going to say Python 3 so make
sure on Windows I think it's just Python
and I'm going to say
main that py and let's go ahead and make
sure everything is good I think let's go
run voila and you can see that we have
our assistant ID because we want to
create that assistant ID we created here
personal trainer and we're printing it
out and we also have the thread let's
see if this is correct because as you
saw we deleted everything in our back
end in our playground and now if we go
back let's see let's go to our
assistants we should see our personal
trainer assistant which was created just
now all right and this ID 7
yt5 you can see 7 yt5 that is exactly
what we have here you can see we have
that personal uh trainer name
instructions and the model that we're
using that's what we specified and so
forth and internally we do have a thread
which is this thread here that is ready
to be used which will have a message so
now this is not working we're not seeing
anything right now but it's okay because
we're going to be using that okay so we
have our assistant and we have a thread
where all the messages are going to be
in and so going back to code here we
understand that if we were to run this
again that would kind of deit the
purpose because we have the assistant
created already it would go ahead and
create yet another assistant which is
not what we want and this is the reason
why in this case here we were able to
get those in this case here you can see
we have the assistant ID as well the
thread ID which we're going to be using
to proceed uh creating and conversing in
this case with our assistant so what I'm
going to do here I'm copy these two real
quick and I'm going to just go ahead and
hardcode our IDs so that we can use them
okay so I'm going to do like that so
this is going to be
assist put that into variables that we
can actually use okay let's not give
spaces so we don't want into issues so
now that we have that we can go ahead
and comment all of this out here okay
I'm going to leave this as is so we
don't need to you will have access to
all this code anyway so now we have what
we need so in this case the assistant ID
when we use that it's going to be um
created right in this case it's going
we're going to be referenced that in
fact I'm going to move all of this uh to
the bottom here because we already have
all of that so I'm going to
also comment this out because we don't
need that anywhere so now we have the
information that we need which is the
thread ID and the assistant ID because
they have been created as you saw in the
back end okay so we'll do next is we're
going to go go ahead and create the
actual message another message here so
we can start conversing with our API
assistance API say
create a
message so I'm going to say message
going to set that to uh let's say say
what are the best
exercises
for
lean
muscles and getting
strong that's our message we're going to
then add to the thread to add to the
thread well I'm just going to say
message again and I'm going to say
client that
better and
threads and I'm going to go to messages
right and then create in this case a
message and for the message well in this
case here the thread will need we need
to pass the thread ID which is going to
going to be the thread ID and we need to
pass the role which is going to be the
user role right because we are
conversing we are asking a question to
them and then the content in this case
is going to be the
message which we created at the top here
and next we are going to then run the
thread or in this case run the assistant
how do we do that well we need to create
that entity first to run our assistant
and to do so I'm going to say run and
then I'm going to use client
again
beta threads that
runs right that create so we need to
create that runs entity which is
attached to the thread and you can see
the beauty here because we said earlier
that run needs to know the assistant ID
that's why we kept it as well as the
thread ID so that they can get message
and added that back to that thread so in
this case I'm going to pass the thread
ID it's going to be thread ID and the
assistant ID it's going to be the
assistant
ID and in this case instructions we need
to pass the instructions for our run
okay so in this case I just going to say
please address the user as James Bond
and there we go so now we have our run
here now we have to remember that our
run has to go through different steps it
could go and find a tool that needs to
be able to assist the user well right to
create to give the assistant more power
things that he needs to do right go
through all the steps that we saw before
uh you may need to then formulate of
course that message back right it's
going to be the assistant message with
the result that the user would want to
receive okay so that takes time because
it's a process so what I'll do here is
I'm going to put together a helper
function that will help help us deal
with the waiting the stepping that the
Run has to do before it gets to the
result right the message is written back
the response Etc okay so for the sake of
time here I do have this wait for run
completion so essentially we're passing
the client and passing the third ID run
ID and then sleep interval is going to
be five now for this to work I'm going
to have to import a few other things
here real quick so because it's going to
calculate in this case the time the
starting time and all of that to give
that elapsed time so I'm going to just
go ahead and paste in the time logging
and daytime from daytime okay so these
are the packages that we need so
essentially what this is doing here is
we're going to wait so while true we're
going to try we're going to go ahead and
uh say client threads retrieve in this
case we're going to pass the thread ID
and the Run ID and then it's going to
check if run completed at and it's going
to go through and get the laps time
we're going to get that and we're going
to subtract so do all the calculation
just to tell us how long this whole
process took it's not necessary but it's
fun to know and then we're going to
print run completed at the elapsed
formatted elaps time and we're going to
log that okay but most importantly this
is where we're actually going to get the
message messages that is once the run is
completed because that's where also the
message that we need the assistant is
going to be spitting out sent to us
that's it's going to be because all that
is going to be put back into the thread
okay so what we do here is we go through
our threads again remember threads
that's where all the messages are the
user's messages as well as the assistant
messages live we're going to go through
that because it's a list and then we
need to pass the thread ID so we can get
those messages that's very important
because you could have multiple threads
going right but on the same assistant so
it's important to understand that we
need to pass the actual ual thread ID so
that we know we're looking at the right
bucket in this case where all the
messages are so we can repreve all those
messages and then we're going to get the
last message okay that is there because
that's going to be our response in this
case and then we're going to go to the
text and get the value okay this is how
we get the response so the response here
is going to go to last which is the
messages go to content and then the text
and the value and we're going to
retrieve that and now here this is where
I'm going to actually run by just
calling the waight for completion and
pass what needs to be passed which is
the client I'm going to call client okay
I could have just because the names are
the same I could just pass client but
let's just say client like this and then
I'm going to pass the thread ID it's
going to be thread ID I'm need to pass
what else uh it says thread ID run ID so
run ID in this case how do we get the
Run ID well we know that we have a run
here which is being passed along right
so we're going to pass that run. ID so
I'm going to say run. ID so we get that
for this to work and there we have it so
when we run this we should see some sort
of result let's see if this works I'm
going to go ahead and open here and
let's say Python 3 main that Pi in your
case if your windows it's got to be
something else let's run if all goes
well it will take a little bit because
it's thinking and we should see once all
is done we should see some
results all right there we go now we
have a result so if you go up here we
can see the Run completed in what would
be 24 seconds right and then the
assistant response well James Bond aha
because we told it to refer as as James
Bond uh when it comes to getting lean
and all that stuff it's essential to
focus on a combination of resistance
training and cardiovascular exercises
there's squats deadlifts bench press
pull-ups chain UPS lunges planks and all
of that great stuff so we got the
response so you can see that this indeed
works right and the other thing you can
do also here is we noticed earlier that
whenever we run something let's go to
test here you can see that we have have
logs so we can actually go and look at
all the logs if you want to in code to
do so I'm going to in fact it's going to
be the steps right of whatever it's
happening all the steps when we say run
the steps goes through so I can do that
as well real quick here to do so I'm
going to say run
steps putting a variable and I'm going
to use
client better again threads and runs and
steps look at that and then in this case
it's going to come in as a list so I'm
going to say that list and I'm need to
pass again you guess it the thread ID
because it needs to know where I'm
getting the steps from or for in this
case and the Run ID which is going to be
run. ID okay and remember this run here
it is what we created earlier here very
very important all right so what I can
do now is I'm going to change the
message here that the user and I can say
how much water
should I drink in a day to get
healthier
okay there we go so let's go back and
open our
terminal and I'm going to run this
again okay so there we go we have a
result here took took about 15 seconds
and to maintain a good health James Bond
it's generally recommended to to aim for
intake of eight glasses roughly 2 lit of
water per day however this is General
guideline blah blah blah and all that
informations very very good ah look at
this stay hydrated 007 prioritize your
health and well-being very cool very
cool indeed so this is very exciting
notice here that now we have this power
of creating
different assistance apis right and
create threads and different threads
actually even within that one assistant
API and we can have all this
conversation and get response so you can
see how easy this is and um this is a
very simple example and later I'm going
to show you how to create an actual bot
or a how to create a bot a chat bot
where you can go ahead and start
chatting and then the assistant will
will respond and you can get information
that way as well which is really
interesting and now you can see the
advantages here right the advantages
that not only are are we just going to
come here in the playground and create
assistance and having to interact with
it here we can obviously but that's not
scalable right because we want to build
application that will leverage this
assistance API and this what we're doing
here is indeed what it's the leverage
that we're given by the assistance API
because now we can use the API the
actual assist API to create uh in code
and attach this to a website or any
application that we may be building
ourselves and then we can also go steps
and look at all the steps right in fact
oh I did not there we go so I
didn't I didn't print the steps let's go
ahead and print the steps oh you
probably saw that and I'm going to put
inside of F string here I'm going to
say steps and say run
steps and that data that's how you get
to the steps data and and then it's a
list okay and voila okay let's go ahead
and run this again of course I didn't do
what I wanted to do because I didn't
print it out but that's okay let's give
a new message how many reps do I need to
do to build lean
muscles okay let's see if this
works and run
again all right and you can see uh we we
know of course this works but what I
want to show you is that we can see
these steps look at this object here
they got ID step ID the assistant ID and
all this information but most
importantly it also has all the things
that were that happened so step details
this message creation details let's just
print that as an object itself just the
data and let's see if we can get more
okay so you can see we have thread the
Run steps and all other this metadata
and when it was completed
the assistant IDs and all this other
information here that was generated type
message creation and voila now I really
hope that you're seeing the whole value
the whole um leverage that we get with
this okay so go ahead and play around
this concept of course as always thank
you so much and I'll see you
next okay so we making real good
progress here so now what we'll do is
we're going to create yet another very
awesome application here called the
current news summarizer assist so
essentially it's going to be a
summarizer a new summarizer that will
allow us to learn a few new things what
we're going to be using in this case is
going to be the function calling tool
now if we go back to what we saw before
when we talked about the assistance API
in the beginning we noticed that we have
the assistance API which Taps into API
models and then in this case it calls
with specific instructions to the open I
model and also can access multiple Tools
in parallel which is amazing because in
this tool list we can have different
things different tools right so we can
have code interpreter can have knowledge
retrieval which we'll see later but the
cool thing also but the amazing thing is
that we also have access to function
calling which is great because it sort
of gives us wings per se which allows us
to create our own tools right meaning we
can create functions that will go be
able to fetch data somewhere or do
something and then retrieve that
information and push it back to the
large language model in this case openi
models and the assistants can then do
what it needs to do so this is the part
that we are going to be look into um in
these upcoming lessons let's go ahead
and take a look at what are we're going
to be building this summarizer
application at least a little demo so
you understand what's going on all right
so this is the app it's called news
summarizer so so essentially this will
allow you to enter any topic I could say
for instance vaccine and then I can run
the assistant so what will happen here
in the back end it's going to go and tap
into a function a call a function
calling a function that was created
which is going to be called by assistant
and that function is actually going to
get an API a news API pull the news that
have this topic vaccine and then
summarize everything for us and as you
can see we have here here are some news
articles on the topic of vaccines and
then we have this other headline here
and great thing is that we also can
click here to go to see more of those
news about whatever is that is being
talked about so it's very cool and so it
gives you some sort of a summary and at
the end of course I added his run steps
which just logs out the uh run Steps
From the assistant as we've seen before
okay it's very cool so this is exactly
what we're going to be building I can
also enter another topic here let's say
Bitcoin why
not and it's going to go ahead and run
this is actually a streamlit application
which I'll show you uh how to put
together it's very simple if you've
never heard of or never even done
anything with stream late it's very cool
okay so it's running as you can see here
and it takes a bit of course because
it's pulling all that information
calling that function and then
retrieving that information and then
pull it back to the AI okay so there we
go we have here here are some articles
on the topic Bitcoin it tells us exactly
what's going on give some descriptions
so this is what we're going to be
building and let's go ahead and get
started so we need to go ahead and get
an API key in order for us to be able to
get this application going so let's go
to newsapi.org as you see here this is
where you are going to go ahead to
either log in if you already have a log
in or go ahead and say get API from here
here or from down here but if you want
to learn a little bit more about what
it's happening here it's a very simple
articles or news API that allows you to
fetch data for instance if you add a
topic such as Tesla as you can see here
in this URL then you get something like
this so a Json that allows us to go in
probing and get information pertaining
to that topic so which is exactly what
we want in this application so it's very
simple go ahead and say get API and the
thing you need to do is to register for
to in order for you to get an API so you
put your first name your last name and
then choose a password make sure you are
if you are an individual or a business
I'll just go with an individual I think
that's the easiest and of course you
have the capture here agree and submit
so I'm not going to do that because I
already have that API so once you have
the API of course as we did before go
ahead and save that API because we're
going to use it uh shortly in our
application I have created already this
news summarizer so I've got environment
going I have everything I also have re
the requirements.txt
with python. EnV and openi of course and
I'm going to say pip install - R pass
the requirement of text and go ahead
make sure that we have all that
installed okay again if you go to my M
bin you can see we should have
uhv as well as opening ey setup for us
so the main folder or the main file as
you see here it is essentially the same
setup we had before okay so just copy
and paste we have the client
instantiated our open
AI here and pass into model of course
remember we could change this model here
to perhaps GPT 4 depending on when
you're watching this video I'm using the
3.5 turbo 16k because that's all we need
anyway but feel free to change that okay
okay so we have all of this imported
nothing new here so if you click here
you can see that I have the open API key
and what we'll do next is you need to
add the other key which is going to be
the news API key so here then you can
put like that and put your API key that
the API key that you created so once we
have all of that let's go back to our
main in this case to our main.py or
app.py and and I'm going to put here
this code so it's going to be news API
OS environment of course we need to make
sure that we import OS for that as well
and then it should be good so here we
are getting the news API we just created
put that into a news API key so we can
use and set things up in a little bit
okay so once you have all that we should
be able to get going now what I'm going
to do next here I'm going to create a
class that will be our manager say our
assistant manager which will allow us to
call it and then get the assistant or
create the assistant the thread ID and
to all the things that we've seen before
okay so I think that's the better way to
do it of course we could do this in a
more modular way uh create functions and
do what we did before but I think this
is kind of fun and also keep in mind
that you will have access to all of this
code so it's all good so in the bottom
here I'm going to put this piece of code
which which allows us of course to pick
up the main function I'm going to create
a here and then run whatever is here so
for now I'm just going to say pass so
that we don't have any issues so let's
go ahead and create a function which is
going to allow us to tap into the API
and get some result that is the base of
this entire application so that is the
first thing we need to do so I'm going
to say get news say Define or def for to
Define and then I'm going to pass here
the topic which is going to be the topic
we're going to pass so first first I'm
going to put the URL here so the URL
that we need to tap into essentially
it's our API so I'm going to I have it
already and I'm going to put inside of
an F string and just go ahead and grab
it so essentially what I'm doing here I
have the htps newsapi.org
and in this case here the end point that
I want is everything okay there are
different end points but we can just
focus on everything and you can go back
to the API page which I will recommend
you do to read a little bit more about
all this end points and everything but
this should suffice and then you have a
query here and pass the topic which is
going to be passed along here and then
the API key which is the news API key
that we put together right at the top
here and of course we're saying page
size about five because we going want to
get more than that but that's just a
little bit too much all right and you
can play around with the numbers and
everything that's totally fine and up to
you now the next thing we need to do
here is go back to to our requirements
txt and I need to pass request package
here because we're going to need that to
hit our API do the request to our API um
and then get the information okay so
let's go ahead and say pip
install oops let's say pip install d r
requirement text voila and we should be
good
go back here now I can go ahead and say
try put all that inside of a try and I'm
going to put say accept at the bottom
here require a
request oh I actually have to import
requests so import requests as such the
package and now I can use the requests
and then acception class
exception as e this is just to say gave
us uh this make some requests and I'm
just going to say print or rather say
error
occurred during API request something
like that okay and then pass the E so
don't worry too much just an exception
here uh because we're going to put put
some code inside of the try here so that
if something happens at least we have a
way of handling our errors right
probably there are better ways of doing
this but this is fine all right so now
inside here we are going to do the
fetching of the response from our API
I'm going to put in a response variable
and I'm going to say request. getet in
this case and pass the URL that's how
easy uh really it is to use request to
go and fetch some data um from the API
so now that we have our response here
I'm going to put some if statements here
just to make sure things are okay so I'm
going to say if response status because
the response will have the status code
in this case if status code is okay in
this case it's just 200 which means
think okay and then I'm going to be able
to parse through our Json so I'm going
to say news and then I'm going to
transform that into Json which means we
need to import Json as
such and say
Json dumps and I'm going to pass pass
our response
Json such and of course I can say
indentation about four as the Json comes
in so to make the actual Json looks a
little bit better okay we have our
object here which is going to be our
payload with all the news so the next
thing we will do here just to make
things simpler is we are going to
transform this Json here we say Json
dumps which if you have over what it
says here it says serialize object to ad
Json format string so this is is just a
format Json string now we need to
actually convert that string into a
python dictionary that way we that way
we're going to be able to access some of
the fields easily so I'm just going to
say J news
Json um and then use
Json package again and say loads and
then pass our new uh this should be news
not new but either way works okay pass
our news here all right there we go so
now this is easy for us to work with
which which is exactly what we want and
then I'm going to say data I'm going to
say use uh Json here just to pass things
around a little bit and then I'm going
to go ahead and uh here I'm going to go
ahead and access all the
fields essentially Loop through right
Loop through the Json and extract all
the things that we want okay so if we go
back to the news API of course we have
to get started documentation everything
but if you look here you can see the
payload how it looks right so all the
payload will more or less look like this
okay which is really cool and also you
can scroll left and down you can scoll
left to see different end points top
headlines and we have here top headlines
still and there we go this is the
everything end point that we are using
and with some modification to get the
data that we're looking for and so it
will look essentially the same the
payload you can see here we have status
it's an object Json object so in this
case it's just an object we have the
status okay results 254 and then we have
this articles array which then we have
the source and the author so each
article is an object itself with all
information and has author title
description and url url image and all of
these fields okay so we're going to
extrapolate some of these fields so that
we can get the information that we need
because we don't need everything from
these uh from the payload so essentially
we're going to Loop through our payload
and get the and access the fields and
get the information that we actually
need so before we even go through the
for Loop um let's go ahead and get some
of the most important Fields so I'm
going to start with status and this
status is going to be getting this
status we're going to get from data and
go to status field here so you can see
we have the object go to status and get
the status field
this case you're just going to say okay
okay we got that and let's get the total
results in this case I'm it's going to
be data and then I believe it's just
total we going down here and get the
total result which will say how many
articles are in this payload and then
we're going to go to articles to get the
actual articles so we going to go
through data again we're going back to
get this array which will contain all of
the Articles as objects or dictionary in
Python okay so we just we just say
articles so this is exactly what we want
make sure that these names are exactly
the same because these are our fields
which are our IDs uh for us to be able
to get what we need I think I got
everything right so I get all the
Articles so now is when I'm going to
Loop through all the loop through the
Articles and get the information that I
want so first thing I'm going to say
for article in articles for simple Loop
here so what we want to do is again go
and get the information that we want
from each article what we want is the
source and get the name and then we may
need the author the title of the article
of course and the description uh we may
need some other things here so and we
may need the content on other things so
we're just going to go ahead and
extrapolate a few of these
fields name in this case going to be
going to articles or article in this
casee for each article and I'm going to
go to source and go through and get the
name all right do the same to others so
I'm going to get the author so
article
author and
title there we go and what else I need
this description which going to be
article and
description and what else let's get the
URL because we may need that the URL to
the article itself and it's going to be
URL okay let's go ahead and get the
content okay what else so that's good
then here at the bottom I'm going to put
all that into a string so it's easy for
us to use it so I'm going to say call
this
title
description I'm going to put all that
into an F
string just to facilitate everything
really and then here's what what's going
to happen so I'm going to go ahead and
concatenate all of these different
pieces that we put together here we
received into a long nice string so
first I'm going to put the
title and then put a text title that
says title first and then I'm going to
say
author so put get the author field that
we just got from here and what else
let's go ahead and get let's say source
source name in this case and description
description and let's go ahead and get
url url okay so now we have this long
string that has all this information
that we pulled from the API looking good
and the next thing we'll do here is that
I'm going to actually put that into an
array because each one of these string
that contains title author Source name
description URL we know that we inside
of for Loop we want to do that for each
one of these articles that we're getting
and so I'm going to go ahead and create
an empty list here say final news that
way I can pass all of that each time
will Loop through okay so right below
here I'm going to say final
news I'm going to pend uh our
description so title description maybe I
should have named it better but that's
okay okay so each time we do that we are
going to pull in all of the Tittle
description which we are getting all of
the title author Source name description
URL for each article as we Loop through
okay all of that so that way we can
actually uh return that array so we see
all of the information in this case all
of the news that we want so at the
bottom here I'm going to go ahead and
just say
return the final
news okay let me go ahead and move this
because this is an if statement I can
say return
else in this case if indeed response if
response once status code is not 200
meaning we have some issues we're just
going to go ahead and return in this
case an empty array Or List like this
all right very good so what we'll do now
is let's go ahead and call our get news
and pass a topic here that says Bitcoin
just to see what will happen let's go
ahead and quickly run
this so I'm going to say Python 3 I am
on Mac so on Windows or Linux you have
to do something something else I believe
and let's call Main let's give it a run
hopefully everything
works looks like it's running but it's
not showing anything that is because I
need to actually put that into a
variable say
news and then say
print news like
this okay let's see if this works let's
run again and as you see we're getting
some information and the great thing is
because if it's an array that we should
be getting yes a list it keep saying
array it's a list in Python but same
thing you can see we have the square
brackets there and of course I can go
ahead and get just the first item in our
list if I wish to do
so and let's run again we should get
just one so we can see exactly that we
have a title and description author
source and all that great stuff and URL
and that's exactly what we want so there
we go so we have all the articles that
we want we just got the pieces that we
want and created one long string and put
that in Array each time we call get news
so this is good news the thing this this
says that this tells us that we're able
to fetch news from our API and get the
data that we want for what we're going
to be doing next so now that we know
that the get news works by the way we'll
see later this get news this is the
function that we're going to be using
you will see in a bit here um as the
function calling functionality we talk
about with assistance API which is
pretty cool okay so now we have that
working we know we're able to pass in in
this case a topic and then we receive
the news right and then we formatted
everything we got what we need and all
is good so we're going to use that as
our function calling very cool all right
so next what we'll do here is as I said
before we are going to actually create a
class this is going to be be a manager
assistant manager class where we're
going to put everything in that one
class okay so now we could have done
this uh just putting functions you know
modularly but this is I think is the
best way okay to do it this is probably
the better way for us to have everything
in one place in one class so we can
instantiate that class as an object and
then get what we want from that let's do
that so I'm going to create a class here
so say class and call this assistant
manager s all right very good and so I'm
going to add a few fields for our class
here the first field that we need is
going to be the thread ID and for now
I'm going to say none and then I need
the
assistant ID which is also going to be
none like this have a Constructor or
initializer depending on which
programming language coming from so
we're going to say Define and this is
going to be the
init and it pass the self and it's
returning in this case um nothing um
just to simplify things of course I'm
going to pass a few parameters here so
it's going to self I'm going to pass
also the model which is going to be a
string okay and just in case I'm just
going to go ahead and pass our model
that we passed at the top here we
created at the top here we have a
default value which is going to be the
model gpt3 or whatever model you added
here and I'm just is going to remove
that and next I am going to then set up
a few things for our class here in our
Constructor in our initializer okay so
I'm going to say self and I'm going to
call the client because I want the
client to be in this case open AI that
open AI as such just to instantiate all
of that or I could have just called our
client here that would work as well so
either way works I'm just going to pass
client like this which is going to be in
this case our client and then of course
self.
model in this case I'm just going to go
ahead and say model whatever we're
passing along here and then self what
else that assistant is going to be none
in the
beginning and
self. thread also is going to be
none and self. run right is none as well
the other thing I'm going to add here
because I want to be able to have the
actual summary because that's the whole
goal is that this class is going to be
able to give us the summary of the news
from the topic that we paste in or enter
so I'm going to create yes another field
here called summary okay which in the
beginning is going to be equal to none
like that so now we're going to do some
if statements here to actually check if
some of these um Fields like assistant
and thread but but more particularly if
this um static Fields here thread ID and
uh assistant IDs if they're existent
that way we can then look at that and
see whether we need to create a new
assistant or just use existing ID
because the idea is that as we run this
the first time as you saw before we will
have the assistant ID at least as well
as a third ID and so that we don't run
this many times and then recreate the
same things in the back end in the
console or in the playground we want to
make sure that those things are set up
so that we don't have copies of the
assistant and IDs and so forth so still
inside of our init here I'm going to say
if assistant
manager. thread in this case let's start
with assistant ID so if we have an
assistant ID that means we have an
assistant in that case we are going to
set our assistant
to the assistant that we already have so
I'm going to say self that client that
beta assistants and then I'm going to
retrieve that assistant and to retrieve
that assistant we need to say pass of
course the ID of that assistant so we're
just going to say assistant ID is equal
to manager assistant manager and get
that assistant ID as such and also we're
going to check for our thread ID if we
have a thread ID so assistant manager.
thread ID if that's the case we're going
to do the same thing we did which is
going to go which is we're going to go
ahead and get the thread ID so self
assistant or thread ID I should say and
set that
up with the self.
client uh
beta threads and retrieve this case
third ID it's going to be to assistant
manager or I could have said self but
that's okay thread ID as such okay all
right very good so now we are making
sure that indeed if we have an assistant
ID then we don't create a new assistant
ID in this case we just go ahead and
retrieve the assistant that we have okay
the same thing with the thread ID okay
so all of that that is inside of our
init function here our Constructor next
we're going to define a new method here
called uh create assistant so this will
allow us to create an actual assistant
so I'm going to pass self name and
instructions as well as tools because
those are the things that any assistant
as you know by now may need when we
create an assistant okay so first of all
I'm going to go ahead and put an if
statement here so if not self that
assistant right so if there's no
assistant of course then what I'm going
to do I'm going to create an assistant
let's say
assistant object essentially and which
is going to be self. client.
beta that uh assistants and then I'm
going to create a new assistance
essentially so to do that we need to
pass name which is going to be name we
need to pass the instructions which is
going to be instructions that we are
passing
along right and then we're going to pass
also tools and pass the tools as such
and for completion we also going to pass
model and we're going to
say
self. model so to get the model that we
already
have in our Constructor in our class at
the top there okay very good so that's
how we would create an assistant if we
didn't have an assistance okay so now
that we know that we've created the
assistant object here next I'm going to
say assistant manager that assistant ID
I'm going to grab that ID and then I'm
going to get that from our assistant
object that
ID like
that and then I'm going to make sure
that the class field has that ID okay
the assistant's ID so I'm going to use
self assistant is going
to and then I'm going to set up the
assistant field which is usually none in
the beginning to the assistant that we
just created here which is going to be
this assistant object right so ass so
self
that assistant now is equal to our
assistant
object very good so if you want we can
just print things out here so that we
can debug and see what's going on so I'm
going to say assist ID just put
something more there so we can see
what's going on and then I'm going to
put say self. assist ID oh I actually
could just go assistant. ID like this
right to get the actual assistant ID
when that is created that why that's why
we're saying this all right very good
and that's it for create assistant okay
so next what we'll do is we are going to
then Define another function or method
in this case uh this is going to be
called
create thread of course I'm going to
pass self so we have
that reference as such so you can see
really nothing is out of this world it's
the process is still the same it's just
that I've changed a few things so that
we have an actual class that helps do
all the things in one place so we can
just instantiate that class and get what
we need all right so the same thing
really if not uh in this case self.
thread so if there's nothing there then
that means we need to create a thread
object okay so sing self.
client and then threads and then I'm
want to create a thread and as you know
now to create a thread we just uh need
to pass we don't actually need to pass
anything things which actually I'm going
to just leave as it so we're going to
create an object thread and we can
attach messages and whatever we need
later all right so now that we have that
thread we're going to use assist manager
just like where we did before and Say
thread ID it's going to be equal to
thread object. ID okay set that thing
that up and then we're going to set the
field the class field self that thread
okay to be equal to the thread object
again we're going to go ahead and
print F string here and Can Say thread
ID just to make things better and just
pass here self. thread. ID all right so
just print it out so we have it and make
sure that we are getting what we need so
now we have created the create assistant
method we also have in this case the
create thread method now we need to add
messages to that thread so I'll Define
another function here say add
message to thread okay so we're going to
pass here first of all self reference
and roll as well as the content all
right in order to create that message
because we know messages are added into
a thread so we need to make sure that we
indeed have a thread ID so we going say
if self. thread we have that then we're
going to go ahead and
self. uh
client beta. threads messages and we're
going to create that message all right
to create a message we need a thread ID
which is going to be in this case self.
thread. ID and then we need the rooll
which is going to be the roll okay which
is going to be passing when we call this
create a message or add message to
thread as well as the content okay and
pass the
content as such which has been passed
along that's it all right so we have
that function or in this case a method
and next we need of course a way for us
to run the assistant so I'm going to
find another method here so this is
going to be run
assistant and we're going to pass self-
reference and instructions as
well okay so how do we do that again
we're going to check It's always
important to check because in order to
run an assistant we need of course to
check if there's a thread ID as well as
the assistant okay so if self. thread
and self
do assistant if they are existent then
we are safe to run this thread so
self run in this case I'm going to set
that to self.
client go to Beta say threads and
runs create okay so we have create here
so what we need to do we need to pass a
few things obviously we need to pass the
thread ID how do we get that we get that
by saying self again right the reference
of this class and we go and get the
thread
id thread. id as such and then we need
to pass the assistant ID do the same
thing and can pass the instructions
which are the instructions that we
passing as parameters okay so our class
is actually coming along nicely next we
going to Define yet another method here
called
process messages because we need a way
as you know to process those messages
going through all that stuff and
retrieve what we need all right so I'm
going to pass here just the self
reference okay let's go ahead and work
on this bad boy so what we need now here
and process message where first of all
I'm going to check if there is a thread
because we can't because we know that
messages are inside of our thread so we
need to check if there is indeed a
working thread in order for us to go in
and get that information which are the
messages so if
thread or self I guess or self.
thread if that's existent if that exists
then I'm going to go say
messages I'm going to retrieve those
messages so
I'm going to go client better for now
that may change by the time you watch
this video this lessons and I'm going to
say threads messages and we know that
comes in a list so let's go to the list
and in this case we need to pass the
thread ID which is going to be self.
thread. ID very good I'm going to create
a list an empty list but that's where
we're going to add all of the messages
or summary in this case right so I'm
going to say
summary an empty list is it an empty
list as such and I'm going to just go
ahead and get the last message of the
thread because that's all that we need
so I'm going to say last message and how
do we get that we say messages but this
is indeed the list right and then get uh
go to data right that's the object and
then uh get the first one zero and I
need to get the role we get the role
from the message in this case payload
which is a a dictionary really that
we're receiving uh we say
messages
again actually since we already have the
last message here we just just probe in
into
that and say
content okay and of course get the first
index and go to text and value as such
oh
value okay so now we get the actually my
this is not R this is going to be the
response all right but I want the roll
which is going to be I'm going to do the
same thing so last message and add
content I believe get to zero and then I
need no actually I can get that straight
to roll I think yeah there we go so we
can see intellisense is helping me very
good so we got the last message the big
object because we looping we know that
the messages come in in a list so we're
probing in and getting what exactly what
we need so we need the last message in
the
list in the message list that we got
from our thread. messages and then we
get the role just need the roll so we
can use it in a bit here and the
response that we're getting all right so
that we can formulate and create a nice
response all right so so we have the
response now I'm going to go ahead and
say print in this case put a inside of
an F string here just for us say summary
and put a lot of information like that
that way we know exactly what's what and
I'm going to say rooll I'm actually
going to go ahead and capitalize the RO
right response like that so we just
printing out the summary and at top I'm
going to put the role so it says for
instance user or assistant in this case
going to be assistant right and then we
pay and then we have our response there
okay so what are we're going to do
before even that we have this summary
here right which is an empty array so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
summary. append and pass in our response
so now our summary when we return
because this is going to return
something I'm going to return real quick
here this is going to return our summary
so now that our summary will have the
response which is exactly what we need
this is going to be the assistant
response right we processing messages so
what we'll do next well you remember at
the top of our class here we have this
field called summary that we
instantiating initializing here to none
so now we can fill that summary into
with the summary that we got here so all
I'm going to
do here now I can say self that summary
and I'm going to just then say summary
like that okay but I want actually to
make it a little bit better which means
I'm going to which means we're going to
format things a little bit so first I'm
going to put a new line every time we
add before we add the actual summary the
actual text in this case
this summary that we get as a response
and then I'm going to call the join and
then pass the the summary as such okay
which is what we have here a list which
will contain in this case U the summary
which is which will contain the
assistant response okay so now our field
summary in this class should have
whatever we getting when we process and
get all of the messages one other thing
we could have done we could have looped
through these messages here because it's
a list right we could have said
something like this for MSG in
messages right we could have say
roll set that to MSG that roll okay and
then
content set that to MSG go to
content say text and get the value as
such and then we're going to print in
this case I'm just going to copy this
something like that say summary
and said roll pass in the roll and also
then pass in the content like this so
this also would have work but because
this is a method and we want something
else to happen um I prefer to do what I
just did here but I'm just going to
comment this out so you have access to
that if you wish to just look at things
in this perspective next we are going to
yet create another function another
method here real quick so we still in
inside of our class it's hard to see
everything because I needed to make the
text a little bit larger so you're able
to see I'm going to say depth to Define
this is going to be wait for
completed and pass
self as well get this function here or
method uh will as the name imply wait
for completed and do what needs to be
done so essentially we're going to make
sure that as we invoke the run and to
run our assistant and do all the things
that need to be done and as you remember
uh when we run we have to go usually we
have to go through certain steps right
those steps may take a little bit so
we're going to configure things along
that way we can wait for a few
milliseconds or seconds until we get the
response and then we do something for it
okay so it's just more of a helper
function in this case method which we we
saw before but now I'm putting that
inside of this class so I'm going to
check of course to see if there is a
thread and also if there is a run entity
that was created so if
self that
thread and self that
run
okay I'm going to put in a while loop
here while true then we're going to go
ahead and going say time. sleep for
about
Seconds okay and then run status
I'm going to retrieve the Run status to
see I'm going to retrieve the Run status
to see where we are by saying self again
go to
client and go to threads and runs and
retrieve okay so in this case here I
need to pass a few things first of all
we need a thread ID which we can get by
saying self that thread get the ID and
then we also need the Run ID which we
can get by self. run. ID and remember at
this point here all of these fields are
of course part of our class the run and
thread and all that so that's real good
that's the beauty of putting everything
into a class where we have one entity
which we can use to do things so all
right so now that we have indeed our run
status we can check that for now I'm
going just go ahead and print something
here put an F string we just say run
status and then I'm going to say run
status we can use the model we're going
to go ahead and say model dump Json
function
there and then we can just add some
indentation in our Json for readability
just say for as such very good so we are
going to go ahead and get this run
status which is which is going to be a
lot of information we getting the model
we are invoking the model dump Json
which if you have over tells exactly
what it does generates Json
representation of the model using penics
and so forth all right very good and
there we go so that's going to be
printed out check the status because
remember the status has uh certain
booleans that tells us where we are in
the process of running these steps right
so we want to check if for instance a
the status is completed or not so I'm
going to say if run status that status
is completed as such and that's the case
I'm going to say
self the process message right we're
going to call our function or method
that we created here the process message
which will know how to process the
messages because that means the running
is completed we should have an answer
right which is good okay so the process
message is called and and then we just
going to go ahead and break now one
thing I want you to remember or to keep
in mind let's go back to our
presentation here so when we looked at
this diagram here where we have talking
essentially talking about the benefits
of the assistance API we said that the
most exciting thing really is the fact
that we have tools so in this case here
we have the code interpreter which we
saw a little bit we have the knowledge
knowledge retrieval which allows us to
upload files and then we can converse
with those files or documents in
addition to the base knowledge that the
models has but the function calling as
well okay right this is where we are we
are going to implement the function
calling how does that work well in this
case here if we look at our code here
when the status is completed then we
know we can we have the messages so we
can go ahead and process those messages
but there's also another status that we
can look for or watch for which is they
requires action because because of the
function calling as we go through all
the steps we saw before remember this so
the steps that the Run goes through you
can use code interpreter create message
to and then call another tool in this
case we're calling a function because it
is indeed another
tool when that happens what that when we
get to that part the Run entity will
know that okay something is required so
it's going to trigger a flag that says
the status now is requires action when
there is this this requirement of
required action that means we can then
call a function do a function call okay
so that is the beauty here so we can
actually look for that so I'm going to
say else if if run status that status is
equal voila you can see it even gives us
all of these enams here right so we have
the requires action right these are
enams that are actually we can get right
Flags essentially that we can get from
the Run status so there is requires
action which is what we need there is
cued in progress failed expired cancel
cancel or cancelling or cancel and so
forth so all of these are steps or these
are states that we can that we can check
each time to do certain things so if the
status says it's been cancelled or
cancelling in the process of counceling
then we can tell the user or send out a
message say hey now this is being
celling so do something else if it's
failed of course we can do something
else if it expired and so if it's in
progress we can also uh maybe shoot
maybe show something for the user
interface to say hey things are uh in
progress so just give it a minute okay
so this is real cool so we want the
requires action because this is what
will allow us to then do the function
calling right which in this case I'll
will tell you now it's going to be the
function that I told you earlier that we
created earlier which is this get news
but we'll get there okay so if this is
the status so if this is the status
requires action what we'll do then we'll
do a few things first of all I'm going
to just go ahead and print here so we
see what's happening I'm going to
say I'm going to say function calling
now CU that's what we need to happen
what we do next is we are going to go
and say self and then we're going to
call this call
required functions should be function
that's fine because you can call more
than one function so say functions going
to pass self and
required actions okay we haven't created
that let's go ahead and create this
actions that's that and all this will do
I'm going to say if not self. run right
if run is not available or so all I'm
going to do here if not self that run
then I'm just going to ahead and
return right because there's nothing
really to do and in any other case I'm
going to just say
tools output and it's going to be an
empty array so this tools outputs here
is what we're going to use to go through
and pull in all of the required Tools in
this case required functions that we
need for this run so let's work on this
little bit a little bit here okay the
thing to remember here because this
required action here here it's going to
be a list that's why it says actions
plural so I'm going to put a for Loop
here that's a for
Action in required
actions and inside of the required
actions actually we are going to have
tools calls as such and then inside I'm
going to go ahead and get the function
name so I'm say funk name and then I'm
going to say action and then I'm going
to go ahead and say function okay
and then I'm going to go and get the
actual name so that's what we're doing
here so we're going to get through
through this required tools but we're
going to have a lot of different tools
we may have more than one tool of course
in this case more than one function okay
and then we're going to Loop through and
just get all of the names of the
functions but in this case we're just
going to have one so we get the name and
put that in function name so if the
function name which is going to be tool
is get news then we're going to get the
actual name of the function but that's
what we need to pass around to get uh in
this case to get it so that the function
can run and then get the data pull it
back then the assistant knows what to do
very good and then I'm going to say
arguments I'm going to say Json in this
case loads and then I'm going to pass
the action so essentially exactly what I
have here I'm just copy this change a
few
things and instead of function name
we're going to get the arguments the
function arguments so all we be doing
here is going through get the function
and get the arguments of that function
because we may need they may have some
arguments that need to be passed around
okay and that's what I'm doing so I'm
going to put that into a variable
arguments okay so we'll see how it all
pans out now I'm going to put an if
statement here so I'm going to say if
Funk
name is equal in this case I know it's
going to be get news now how do I know
this well I know this because that's the
function I need to be called as a
function calling it's called get news if
you said happy birthday or James Bond
whatever you named here this has to be
exactly the same because that's what
we're going to be calling right so if
function name is get news in this case
then what we'll do well we're going to
put inside of we're going to say
output and must called get news aha now
I'm actually calling the function and
passing the topic how do I get the topic
well I get the topic because I have the
arguments remember when we did this here
we're getting the arguments of the
function so we need to pass the actual
arguments here like
that okay now what is the arguments now
the cool thing is that when you go back
to this get news here the argument name
is topic right
so in this case here I need to say well
the arguments because it's going to come
in as just a dictionary it's going to be
topic as such very very important so
whatever you put inside of get news
function when you call the argument has
to be passed along like this very good
so that is part of the function calling
guys all right so now that we have the
output because get news is going to
return something or it's going to give
us something right and we have that
there as an output now I'm going to go
ahead and print that just so we have it
F string here just say
stuff okay to differentiate things and
I'm going to say output like
this because we know that the get news
will return that very nice string right
remember let's go back here can see I'm
going to open
this so we return this final news which
is going to be a a string but in this
case it's just going to be a list
containing all of those different new
news right because we listed everything
we put everything in one string and we
Loop through so each news that we
getting we going to get a title author
Source description URL and so forth and
put that in final news list right
so in this case here what we'll do is we
are going to Loop through and so that we
can create the actual final string so
I'm going to Loop through and extract
everything from the list because that's
what's been returned from our get
news and then I'm going to put
everything in a very long string that
way it's easier for the L for the llm
for the model in this case to be able to
just pick all that stuff and and
summarize it and create some sort of a
new uh summary of everything if that
makes any sense okay so structuring
things for us so I'm going to say final
string Str just make it an empty string
as
such and then I'm going to say four item
in
output then we're going to do something
so I'm just going to append like I said
to create that long string so final
string plus equal I'm going to just
say that join and pass in this case our
item okay now we have this final string
ready for us to use all
[Music]
right okay so you notice here we also
have what we call this tools output
should be tool outputs so our tools
output here is just an empty list so
we're going to use that cuz that's where
we're going to add all of the tool
outputs so I'm going to say tool outputs
in this
case and append what well I'm going to
pend an object or a dictionary that will
have a few things first of all let me
just put it all together here so you can
see first of all I'm going to say tool
and call ID like that and then for the
call ID so how do I get the call ID well
a call ID it's going to be coming from
our action if we say action right what
is the action well action is this
because we're still inside our for Loop
right so it's going to go through all
the tool calls so I'm going to get each
one of the action which part which is
essentially the action part of the
function right the function call and I'm
going to go ahead and get the ID so I'm
going to say like this and say ID so I'm
getting the tool call ID in this case we
call it's going in this case essentially
it's just the function the function
function calling right say output this
is going to be the output that comes
from our get news so what I'm going to
do well I already have this final string
here so that's what I'm going to put
here so I'm going to say final string
like that very good now this tool
outputs is very important as you can see
in a little bit here so now that we have
our tool outputs with stuff that means
each time we go through it's going to go
ahead and get all of the tools in this
case it's just one function you could
have other tools right uh we're doing
call uh function calling here it's going
to go ahead and get the action ID and
get the final string which is what we
get from our output when we call the
actual function the actual tool this is
our tool right very good so next what we
do I'm just going ahead and print
something here so we see what's
happening going say
submitting outputs back to the
assistant that's what we'll do next
right here so now before I do that
actually I'm going to say something like
else because we're inside of if
statement if the function name is
getting news right so if any anything
else happens I'm going just say raise
value error and I can just say something
like an F string here
unknown
function and then I'm going to just put
the funk name as such okay just to save
ourselves from a lot of issues so I'm
going to get out of our if or for Loop
that is here all of that has to be
inside of for Loop and now I'm going to
say submitting output put back to the
assistant so what we'll do next is ah
this is the beauty I'm going to say self
client beta and then threads and runs
and submit tool so there is such
function or such in so there's such
function called submit tools output or
tool outputs that's why we were doing
all of this but now we have to pass
along a few things in order for the run
in this case here to be able to go and
get the tools because at this point it's
saying hey we need some tools right
tools required right in order for that
to happen then we need to pass a few
think it needs to know about the thread
ID which we can get from our
thread. ID right it needs to know about
the Run ID all right so I'm going to say
can know about self. run. ID it also
need to know about the tools outputs and
where do we get those well tool outputs
which is exact what we've been working
on around here now we have tool outputs
we will have tool call ID it has to be
exactly like this that is what's
required and the action ID we're passing
to like call it same right we have here
tool call ID which needs to be passed
exactly like this in this dictionary and
if it's going to be action ID and output
is going to be the final string which is
exactly what we have here which is the
information coming from our get news
very cool very cool all right now indeed
if we go back to where we were calling
this this will make more sense now I
don't need to pass that at all nor do I
need to pass that let's see what do I
need to pass so now this makes sense
that means now when status is requires
when status is requires action we are
going to call required functions which
is what we just did so it's going to go
through and go and get all the tools in
this case it's just going to go ahead
and say okay so we need a function in
this case but because it could be more
than one function because it's a tool
itself go through all the process we
make sure the function name is exactly
the name that we created at the top as I
showed you and then we get the output
from that function but those results are
needed right for the run to process
everything and we do all this great work
and then we make sure that then we
submit those tools as you see
here okay to our uh run runs that submit
tool function you need to pass the
thread ID as well as run ID always all
right very cool all right so there we go
that is exactly what's happening here
and so now we should be able to have
everything that we need to get things
going but before we go that we need to
pass something else here says here H
required actions so we need to pass the
required action here what do we how do
we do that well it's going to be I'm
going to say required actions and it's
going to be run status that required
action
submit uh tool
outputs and I'm going to say model say
model dump like that so essentially we
are just getting the submitter tools and
of course we are going to go ahead and
generate in this case and of course
we're going to make it so that it is
indeed a model Dum so create a a python
dictionary which is needed so that the
call required function knows how to read
all that stuff which is needed that is
needed for the function calling to
actually
work okay so what I want you to do is to
if this is not making a lot of sense
it's okay uh rewatch this part a few
times until you understand it the main
thing to keep in mind here is that all
of that is being called inside of wait
for completed but that's where all the
action is and we are setting up or we
are listening right looking for the
status if it's completed then we just
are good we go ahead and process message
in cases which is this case here where
status says requires action that's when
we call required functions right because
this again I'll repeat myself I know but
I want you to understand this is where
all the getting the function name
getting the IDS the action ID and
everything and actually calling our
function as a tool this is where
everything happens and it's very
important to make sure that we get the
arguments and pass the actual arguments
which are passed along when we call that
function which we created the get news
and make sure the function name is
getting there and everything is good and
life is great all right so that's very
important to keep in mind now I know it
was a little bit of working that needed
to be done but that's how you do
function calling you with the assistant
API next we are going to create yet
another function here or method I should
call it because it's inside of a
class this is going to be for streamlet
and we're going to talk about that in a
little bit this is going to be our front
end right going to say here for
streamlet so essentially we're going to
define a method here called get summary
pass self and all it will do is this is
going to go ahead and
return self. summary as such okay that's
all this function is doing here and it's
going to be more apparent once we are
putting together the front end with
streamate so the next method we're going
to create here is the run method so run
the
steps Define this run
steps reference self and I'm going to
say run steps
self.
client go to threads
runs and steps as such and pass in the
list and we've seen this before so we
are going to of course go through the
Run steps and get all that information
for that we need to pass the thread ID
as you know so
thread self of
course get the ID as well as the Run ID
so it's going to be
self run.
ID okay very good and so we're going to
go ahead and just go ahead and print in
this case and have string say run
steps and pass in the Run steps so we
can see what's going on this is just for
us okay so I think these are all the
methods that we
need we have a few here so we have we
have the call required functions we have
the process message we have the Run
assistant these are very important
because allow us to actually create
assistants which is the most important
thing really and add to thread but
before that we have the create thread
and create assistant which one was this
this
was run assistants of course to run an
assistant and we have the create
assistant this is the one I wanted to
talk about and voila so we have our
class here assistant manager which we
can instantiate as an object and we're
going to be able to run and create
assistance and do all the things that
we've done before but in a different
more um objectoriented way of doing
things and most importantly that we know
that indeed the get news which we tested
earlier here this is a tool that's going
to be using in the process in the
function calling tool as we discussed so
very exciting okay so now I think it's
time for us to test this out so let me
move this
main to the
bottom right about
here and so I'm going to comment
this let's comment this out as well as
that as course for testing and first of
all we are going to go ahead and say a
manager create a variable manager and
then estan shate our assistant manager
as such okay very clean and what we'll
do next is we are going to be using
streamlit which will allow us to create
a web page where we can actually see
things happening so it's very simple and
of course I'm going to go up here and go
to requirements and I'm going to go
ahead and say stream lit such and make
sure that I've run again pip install d r
requests requirements a text
so we can pull in this streamlet package
okay so looks like we've gotten
everything let's make sure it should be
fine let's see streamlet is there that's
very exciting really good so let clear
this and now I can go ahead and we can
now use streamlet again if you don't
know what streamlet is again streamlet
is just a very simple framework that you
can use Python firw workk you can use to
quickly generate web pages with python
it's really beautiful create a streamlet
interface so we can actually create a
user interface of course that's what it
does I'm going to use streamlit first of
all I need to go ahead and import
streamlit as St for streamlit okay so
now I can set things up here I'm going
to start by putting the title so
st.
title it's going to be
news
summarizer and then I'm going to add
here a form which will allow us to add a
field where we can in this case add
where we can type where users can type
in the topic so I'm going to say with
sd. form and for any form we need to
pass a key okay so I'm going call it
user
input form and then I'm going to pass
instructions here I'm going to s that
text area so we can actually create a
text area or text input I'm just use
text area because it's cool and I'm
going to say what I want the text to
show here is going to be enter topic
maybe text error is too much let's just
uh say that text input okay that's
probably better all right and we're
going to also create a submit button
such and I'm going to St do form submit
button and I'm going to pass a label
which is going to be just a string I'm
going to say
run assistant and now we need to be able
to handle the button U let me see
something here I'm going to run this
real quick just to see if something's
going to happen now in order for us to
run a streamlit application we no longer
say python we say stream lit run and
then the name of
the file hit enter and if all is well
what will happen a new window is going
to open okay so you can see I have have
it open now it looks really nice and new
summarizer we can enter something and we
have the button here so just like that
we're able to create a user interface
that looks
wonderful next let's go ahead and handle
this submit button because we want once
the submit button is clicked something
needs to happen so I'm going to say if
submit button in this case that's how
you handle submits we're going to go
ahead and create an assistant and thread
if they don't exist so I'm going to call
the manager
because we instantiated here and I'm
going to say
dot create assistant look how beautiful
this is because now we can just go ahead
and call those methods right the
function in this case from our manager
object class that we created and for
that we need to pass a few things I'm
going to pass the
name the name is going to be news
summarizer as such and then I'm going to
pass instructions and I already have
those instructions I'm just going to
copy and add them here so that way we
don't have to do all of
this okay so essentially it says here
your personal article summarizer
assistant who knows how to take a list
of Articles title and descriptions and
then write a short summary of all the
news articles now the most important
thing here is that we need to pass the
tools list right so the list is going to
go in as an object or a dictionary in
this case and we need to pass a few
things here so now I have all of that
already and you'll have access to all of
that this is um the dictionary that you
need to pass in for our function calling
to work so instead of tools you say this
so we have the type is going to be
function the function we're going to get
the name is get news remember it has to
be the same name of the function we
created earlier get news very important
and then the description we can add a
description here for that function we
have the parameters and then we have the
parameters and and then we have the
parameters fied which is an object or
dictionary it's going to be an object
the property and importantly notice here
the property is the topic this is the
argument right so topic is going to be
type of string and we need to pass the
description of that property which is
topic remember we adding topic because
that was the argument we're passing has
to be exactly the same name this is very
important otherwise it's not going to
work okay and so we pass the description
the topic for the news for example
Bitcoin and so forth now important part
here is a required because this is going
to be the argument parameter as you see
this is part of parameters and that is
required which is going to be the topic
notice these are the same names as the
arguments or parameters we passed in the
function okay so when we click the
button then we're going to create an
assistant and then also we are going to
go ahead and create right below that
we're going to go ahead and create
create the actual thread because that is
needed right to create a thread going to
use manager again and then invoke the
function or run the function or call the
function create thread we don't have to
pass anything and next we're going to go
ahead and add the
message and run the assistant as such
how do you do that well we're going to
use manager again this is the beauty of
having that class right and call the add
message to thread function and here we
need to pass the role the RO is going to
be user content it's going to be I'm
going to pass in as an F string so I'm
going to
copy what I have here already so it's
easier so for Content says summarize the
news on this
topic and passing the instructions now
where is this instructions coming from
well this is the instructions we getting
from the text
input very good once we've added that
message this is going to be a message to
the thread right what we need to do then
is just say
manager that run
assistant right that method and passing
the
instructions which is going to be
summarize the news okay you can be more
elaborate but that's
okay and once we have that then we are
going to wait for
completion and process then the messages
okay so I'm going to call manager again
say wait for completed it's called wait
for completed it should be wait for
completion so I already so we have that
so change that so that wait for
completion and then we're going to have
a summary here which is going to be
which then I'm going to call the
manager. get
summary because at this point we should
have a
summary and once we have this summary we
can then say St for stream lit and write
that summary
okay into our page and then SD again I'm
going to add a text here which is going
to be the Run
steps and then I'm going to st. code so
this is just going to show the Run steps
at the bottom and then I'm going to pass
it's called manager that run steps
function which we created right is just
go ahead and show all the steps and I
want this line numbers to be true as
such that's about it so we are now
calling everything first of all we
created the assistant make sure that we
pass the tools which is going to be a
function function calling tool
essentially and then we create the
thread that's needed and then once the
thread is created we I'm going to create
in this case add call the add message to
thread add the user and the summarized
news on this topic which is going to be
instructions right and we're going to
run the assistance past instructions we
going to wait for completion right a few
seconds and then we get the summary
manager get summary and then we write
that summary into
our into our page and then of course we
also get the steps so we can show at the
bottom that's it so now if I save this
go ahead and run again I think uh I
could go back
and always run okay let's go ahead and
say open
Ai and
run all right so after a few moments you
can see that we have here here are some
recent news articles about openi and
goes and gets the title how to stop
another open ey meltdown and it's got
all the main points the author Source
description so what happens now in the
back end the assistant was able to go
and create this all of this the
description as a little summary okay the
same thing with wired so everything
related to the description here is
indeed showing now it's saying none here
maybe perhaps in the code I put
something wrong but that's okay we can
look at that a little bit later okay so
as you can see this is indeed working
and if we go back to our command line
here or terminal I should say there's a
lot that has shown up here and let's see
so we see here in one of the Run status
we have the assistant ID so I'm going to
copy that assistant ID and go back to
our code and for our assistant ID here
I'm going to actually paste that in and
let's go ahead and find the
thread ID there we go to thread ID let's
just copy
this and I'm going to put there so this
is what we're going to be using very
well so that means then I'm going to go
ahead and stop this all together because
now we're going to change gears to make
sure that we don't recreate this same um
we don't create yet another another
assistant when if we were to run this in
this case um adding another something
else okay so I stop that and this is
stopped now if we go
to open AI let's go to our assistance we
should see that indeed we have this new
summarizer assistance with that ID which
is the same ID that we just added
hardcoded to make sure that everything
works as
intended okay so now that we have
actually added this thread ID as well as
assistance ID we have this code so that
it will check if there's already an
assistant ID okay if there is an
assistant ID we just going to go ahead
and retrieve that assistant right say
assistant better assistance and retrieve
same thing with the thread okay so this
is why we had this code before so now if
I save this let's go ahead and rerun
again going to refresh this so this time
here I'm going to run again let's have a
different topic let's say
US
inflation let's go ahead and write R so
we'll take a few moments and there you
have it here are some recent news
articles about US inflation and we have
the title the author and everything and
we do have that description which is
really nice and we also have to read
more the homelessness in the US hit
record high and all this information
very good so we still getting none for
steps here we can look at the code just
to make sure because for
steps I saw earlier that we should be
getting something but I think I I let's
see okay I have run steps let's go to
our
code okay run
steps I'm just run steps self list right
I'm printing the Run steps and I
should return H that's why run steps
like this and of course I can
move this there so this actually works I
can actually save this and I'm going to
prob in into data to actually get the
right information all right there we go
so now if I go back
here and I'm going to say always rerun
or just rerun one time that's okay and
I'm going to find something else let's
say let's say apple okay after a little
bit you can see that indeed this is
running here are some recent news
articles about Apple and Apple pay Apple
card Apple
Visa TV and all this great stuff so you
can see oh there we go and of course we
have all the Run steps which is exactly
what we want to see and this is just for
us to debug of course in a final project
or product you shouldn't you probably
shouldn't have this there but I just
want to show you so we have this is
working if we go to our assistant we see
that we don't have duplicates of
assistant we just have one summarizer
because now we're able to get the
assistant ID and of course we printed
out the thread ID so we're using those
for our assistance API that we heating
creating here to summarize our news very
cool so I hope this is making sense I
hope you are seeing the power of using
function calling uh with assistance API
and it's part of adding more tools to
the toolkit so that an assistant is able
to run things and get information extra
information from somewhere else as you
can see we're tapping into a totally
different thing per se totally different
system uh API in this case to get
information and pass that back through
the large language model in this case
the model that we're using large
language model that we're using here
gpt3 we instructed it to create a
summary get that information and
summarize everything and then pass it
back to the thread as the response and
that's what we getting here and you can
see a lot of different use cases that
can come up from this right you can
create for instance a newsletter
application that what it would do is
depending on the topic that you pass in
here it will just create General
generate a newsletter with the main
points about that topic so the things
you can do are literally endless there's
so many things you can do with this and
I hope you're seeing uh the power that
we have here okay so all of this is just
using the assistance API okay so so far
we've done a lot of things and the last
thing we did was to create this
summarizer new summarizer with which
allows us to look into uh passing tools
passing function calls to our assistant
that way we can extend even more the
toolings that we can pass to theist to
our assistant to do something else right
so in this case the assistant now has
this function call we just looked at one
function call but you can have many
function calls and this is very
important because that as I said will
extend the capability of our model
because not only can we rely only on
what the large language model knows now
we can include out tools so that the
large language model the model model in
this case will have more context more
knowledge base so that's what's all
about so it gives us that flexibility
and what I want you to do is to think
about use cases that you can Implement
at your work or maybe in your projects
what else can you do the example that I
showed you here was tapping into or
calling in this case an API news API but
you could tap into uh a database for
instance or do all sort of things so the
idea is that now you have that
capability and you see how function
calling is really awesome when it come
to creating really powerful assistants
so next what we'll do is we're going to
look at a knowledgebase retrieval tool
because now we're going to look at how
to even give more context more knowledge
specific knowledge that we would want to
our model so that our assistant is able
to have the knowledge to answer certain
questions and get us the results that we
want okay what would going to be
building is what I call a study body
essentially will allow us to upload
certain PDF files and then we can type
and questions in the chat Boot and get
answers pertaining to that to those
documents or that document that we have
uploaded okay but before we do that
let's talk a little bit about the
background of how things work how this
retrieval thing really works right in
the back end so how does it work this
knowledge retrieval the way it works is
very simple if you look at this we have
documents a document could be whatever
we upload in this case let's think of it
as just a PDF file okay so what happens
now is that we pass that or we upload
that to openai large language model
which has this Lang which has this
massive knowledge base but when we pass
these documents in that means those
documents or files are now part of these
large language model knowledge base
that's the whole idea so that way when
we query or we ask questions to the
model which now understands more than
what it knows because we've passed more
knowledge per se then we can get the
answers so this is what we have in a n
shell but there's a lot of things that
are happening internally here one of the
things is if you
look inside right so what happens now is
that we're taking a document and we put
it through
a document splitting process okay so the
documents are split or cut up into
smaller chunks and then those are
actually saved in what we call a vector
store now this is what generally happens
when we talk about when we talk about
pushing information in this case
documents and so forth to the large
language model so it has more context
has more knowledge okay so the question
here is okay what is this Vector store
and why is that even important the thing
to keep in mind here is that in a vector
store the representation of the document
is not is not the same as we started
with so this is not even documents chunk
this is not even a document that you and
I can read anymore now we have this
different representation that we call
embeddings so what happens that a vector
store holds embeddings so embeddings is
a vector just a mathematical
representation of the text of those
documents and that is indeed what is put
inside of the vector store a vector
store is just a database that holds all
of this mathematical representation of
our document now the reason why
embeddings are so important is because
embeddings are first of all our
mathematical representation which means
it's really easy for algorithms to be
able in this case to search for whatever
it's looking for for your text for
meaning and so forth so there's a lot
more to that but that is is the idea
because now we can look for pieces of
text in this case we call text but
they're not necessarily text they're
mathematical representation but let's
call them text so now it's easy to look
for the pieces of text and trying to
find similarities between those pieces
of text which are now embeddings the
idea so visually again this is what
happens so you have all the documents so
I'm putting different kind of documents
but right now we're talking about just
PDF files but could be anything really
in general okay and that has to be
transformed into embedding as I just
said which are these mathematical
representation of those pieces of data
the text or the document which we call
Vector
representation and that is what is
pushed into this massive algorithm that
will then know how to do the similarity
search to find the right results per se
okay so the idea here is as follow the
query the questions also have to be
transformed into embeddings so that they
are able to be understood and be
searched for because if the information
now is in the vector representation
format makes sense that the answer or
rather the question the query has to be
the same format that way the algorithm
is is able to do the searching in the
vector store and so forth and get the
right information and of course that
gives us the result so essentially this
is what how it looks like again okay so
we have the vector store loading so this
is not necessarily just what happens uh
with open AI in this case are we talking
about it but I'm talking about in
general this is what would happen so in
this case here we have the document
loading so what happens then we split
everything and then all the splittings
those are the vector representation of
our documents here they put into a
storage a vector store okay now the
retrieval in this case everything is
going to be indexed right so now we have
a question or a query we go through
through the vector store the retriever
so we retrieve the relevant splits
because the information now it's into is
in this different format and now the
search happens to find what goes with
what what makes more sense right to find
the most similar pieces of data so that
we understand what's going on and then
once that is retrieved the most similar
pieces of data that's what it's then put
into a prompt all right so we have that
prompt the query and we have that what
we've received from the retrieval the
documents were split and everything and
with the prompt and with the help of the
large language model in this case just a
model that's when we get the answer so
this my friends this is how it works in
the back end now if we go ahead and look
back at the first the open AI you notice
that in this case open eye simplifies
everything for us when it comes to this
whole process
because now we have some sort of like a
a black box where all of the things that
I've just told you now is happening all
we have to be concerned about is to get
a document push them into this black box
per se and then we can just start
conversing with our large L model in
this case our model in this case in the
form of our assistant API so this is
what we're going to be doing next next
we're going to learn how to do knowledge
retrieval by pushing or by uploading
files in this case documents to our
assistant's API and then be able to ask
questions about those documents so I
went ahead and created a new project
called study body and I've set up the
environment environment variables and
everything and I also have requirement
uh. txt we have all of these Let's see
we don't need request anymore I don't
think that's okay so let's go ahead and
run pipe install real quick here
R request so we can get all those
dependencies all right so we got all
those dependencies that's very good and
what we'll do next let's get rid of that
in our app here everything should be
looking good nothing new I've got a few
Imports as well some of them we're not
going to use them that's okay we can get
rid of them when we need to and one
thing I noticed I've changed here is
that is that now for a model we have GPT
4 110 six preview now remember these
could change depending on when you're
watching this you can go to the
documentations and see that okay but
this should work so the first step we
need to do is to is how do we upload
files to the assistant API in the back
end okay so let's put number one here
upload a file to
open AI embeddings essentially that's
what we're doing ah embeddings yes okay
so to do so first of all we need to get
those files and I already have that
prepared for us so I'm going to go ahead
and get it the one file at least which
is going to be in this case this is the
understanding cryptocurrency it's very
short not nothing too large that's okay
and we're going to use that and upload
that to the embeddings the open AI
embeddings okay so I'm going to say file
path I'm going to create a file path
here and because it's literally here so
what are we going to do we just going to
go ahead and say that for Slash and of
course make sure that you know depending
on what operating system you're on so
this is how we do in on Mac so I know
it's cryptocurrency so I'm going to uh
crypto
currency. PDF that's the name so make
sure the name is exactly the same and
then I'm going to create an actual file
object and I'm going to say client Cent
right
beta and I'm going to files let's see no
it has to go client files it's not beta
which is good so and then let's say I'm
going to create and I'm going to pass
the file I'm just going to say open and
then find uh pass the file file
path as such and I'm going to say
RV and we need to also pass the purpose
why we are uploading this in this case
I'm just going to say that purpose is
going to be equal to assistant
assistance like
that okay there we go so now we have let
me put this perhaps in a new line no
doesn't work so now we've created the
actual file object which is going to be
pushed into the open AI embedding in
this case the open AI assistance API
okay okay and then then
step number two very simple is we're
going to create an assistant oh we've
done this many time so you should know
how to do this now so I'm going to just
go ahead and do it anyway so assistant
I'm going to use our client going I have
to do beta for now assistance. create
and we have to pass a few things first
of all it's going to be name I'm going
to call this
study
buddy and then instructions and I have
the instructions here so I'm not going
to bore you so I'm going to just get all
of that and show you here okay so I do
have the instructions here you are a
helpful study assistants who knows a lot
about understanding research papers Your
Role is to summarize papers and do all
these things so you're going to have
access to all this so there's no need
for me to go through but it's important
to remember that whenever you're
creating these instructions these are
the prompts so you need to be very
thoughtful and very
um specific of what you want this
assistants to be able to do next the
important thing thing here is tools the
tools we're going to have to pass here
or essentially simple we're going to
pass just one tool and the type of this
tool I'm going to say it's going to be
retrieval because we want to be able to
upload a file or
files okay I'm going to say model in
this case I'm going to say model pass
the model that we created at the top and
then we need to pass has also file IDs
notice it says ID is not ID that means
we can pass more than one file and
that's why we have a list here so I'm
just going to go ahead and say the file
object. ID like this okay this file
object again remember that's what we
created here and for reasons that you
know by now I'm just going to go ahead
and get the
assist ID so we can use it later later
so I'm going to say assist ID I'm I'm
going to use the assistant and get the
ID I'm going to go ahead and print that
one assist ID and then I'm going to just
paste some of the code here this is for
later once we've run once so we have the
uh the thread ID and assist ID then
we're going to add them here so these
are old ones and they're not going to
work so for now just going to go ahead
and uh make them empty as such so and I
can also go ahead and go like this for
now and next I'm going to go ahead and
create in step
three we create a thread again nothing
new here same thing okay so first of all
I'm going to create a message here and
for now I'm just going to say what is
mining something like that that's okay
so let me go ahead and create a thread
here so thread uh just client
beta threads and we just go ahead and
create a thread need no need to pass
pass anything and let's go ahead and get
the thread ID right away that ID let's
go ahead and
print thread ID li like
that say
run the
assistant so I'm going to say
run
client threads runs create
eight okay and we need to pass the
thread ID so it's going to be
thread ID as such
and assist ID going to be assist
ID and instructions I can just put
something here that says
please address the user as Bond as Bru
I'm also going to go ahead and pull in
this weight for run completion we've
seen this before so no need for me to go
through the idea is that it's going to
go ahead and wait for a few moments make
sure that everything is running and then
it's going to give me the time formatted
elapse time to say how long it took to
run and everything okay so we've seen
this before that's what we're going to
be using of course to run right through
our uh to run it so now we're going to
go ahead and say run it how do we do
that I'm going to say wait completion
and then I'm going to pass the client
which is going to be our client and
let's pass the thread ID it's going to
be thread ID and let's pass the Run
ID which is going to be run. ID as such
okay because we have the run here okay
and of course if you want we can check
the Run steps logs and this we've seen
that before so there we go so very
simple um let's go ahead and run this
most importantly we know hopefully that
we're going to be able to push this
cryptocurrency PDF um file into open ey
embeddings right so it's going to go
into do all the things that I've showed
you before what happens in the back
end and we should have an assistant
let's go ahead and run this real quick
if all goes well we should be able to go
so I'm going to say
Python
3 that's that and run so we got some
things here but let's go ahead first and
get the assistant ID so we copy that and
add it here let's get the thread
ID and put it here okay so that next
time we can run things differently so
let's go to open AI here the assistance
in the back end let's see if this
actually worked if I go ahead and
refresh here we should see indeed that
we have study buddy this is our new
assistant there is the ID and everything
is good if I click of course we have all
that information and the model that it's
using and most importantly we see that
the retrieval is ticked as well as the
cryptocurrency PDF file was uploaded
this is real great we knew this would
happen of course but it's always nice to
see and most importantly says assistant
response to document understanding C
currency by the University of Kentucky
blah blah blah so it goes through all
the things really and does a a summary
of the everything okay which is good and
also we have the Run steps and voila so
nothing new what we seeing but most
importantly we know that things are
working because we got the document
uploaded and this it's part of the
knowledge base now okay let's go close
this and now that we have the IDS right
so we don't have to go back and recreate
the same assistant uh we're going to
hardcode them here this is just for
testing purposes and now we no longer
need to create this so I'm going to go
ahead and comment this out as well as
comment this out and what else I'm going
to comment this out
also cuz we don't need that so now
before we run I can then create the
actual message so I'm going to say
message is equal client beta
threads messages and I'm going to create
a message which means I have to pass the
thread ID pass the thread ID right and
roll
it's going to be
user and content aha this is where we
pass our message which is the query per
se what is mining okay so now you should
get an answer of what is mining because
we have added or pushed into the
embeddings right uh the file in this
case the PDF file about cry
cryptocurrency so it should know how to
answer to that let me go and save this
make sure everything is
good okay so everything seems to be
great let's go ahead and run
again so that means now we should be
able to
see the answer pertaining to what is
mining so it's going to go and get look
at the document that we uploaded and
answer according to that document so
assistant response mining is a process
through which uh cryptocurrencies can be
obtained it involves the creation of
block and blah blah blah and everything
it tells us that this was actually able
to get the information from that PDF
file which is wonderful so this is
working so there we go it's very simple
if you go back to the code here you can
see we still have uh one hopefully just
one because we didn't repeat things
right we have study body and everything
is there and if I click I should have
still the file and I can upload as many
files as I want of course we'll get
there but the basics is here so so
you're able to see how to get in this
case retrieval the knowledge retrieval
how to get this to work by uploading a
file a PDF file to enhance the knowledge
base for our assistant API all right
there you have it now that we know how
to upload files and Converse per se ask
questions uh about that file in this
case the PDF file that we uploaded in
conjunction with our assistance API it
is time for us to do something a little
bit cooler which is to build our study
body so the idea is we're going to
upload the file the one that we're
uploaded now and maybe another file and
then start chatting and asking questions
about those files or those PDF files
documents let's go ahead and do that so
what I'm going to do here I'm going to
create yet another file uh to
differentiate a few things so I'm going
to say main.py or py and the
differentiation is going to be little I
would say minimal so let me
get all of these code from the app file
and pass it
over so we have everything here let's
see and actually we need to get the
IDS because we need them I'm going to
copy
that and put them
here and and in this case we no longer
need that so let's just get rid of that
all
together all right now because the
nature of this application this is going
to be a stemulate application there are
a few things that we need to do to set
everything up so the first thing I'm
going to put here is the nature of
streamlit is that we need to make sure
that we have sessions and any time you
hit enter or click a button uh in a
stream lad application what it happens
that it's going to go ahead and reload
the entire application the entire view
or the entire window which is not what
we want so uh I'm not going to go into
this whole session thing with streamlet
just this is going to help us especially
when we want to create uh this chatbot
using streamlet and the great thing also
about streamlet is that all of that is
included so there is actually a chat
form that we can create quickly with
streamlit that's why streamlit is pretty
cool okay so first I'm going to go ahead
and initialize all the sessions that we
need okay okay so I'm going to start by
putting an if statement here if file
ID list so this is going to hold all of
the file IDs because potentially we can
upload more than one
file and not in sd. session state if
that's the case then we're going to
create that
session session state. file
IDs list and that's going to be just an
empty list okay we just have to do this
and I'm going to do another one as well
so if
start chat which is going to be part of
a button really not in sd.
session
State s the session that
start chat I'm going to just say it's
going to be
false what else now I'm going to use the
thread if thread I ID not
in session State and then we're going to
say St session
state
DOT
thread okay very good those are the
sessions we need to set up okay we're
going to go straight and start setting
up the front end in this case the page
so I'm going to go ahead and just say
set up our front end
page and to do so with it is extremely
simple I'm going to say St and then set
there's a function called set page
config and here we can pass a few things
so I'm going to say page title say
study
buddy say chat and learn that sounds
very good and Page icon we can actually
pass an icon here like this books okay
so you just put this is the icon
representation of a stack of books this
is where we're going to start our
function
definitions
Etc so essentially this is where the fun
will start so the first thing we need to
do is to figure out a way to upload a
file to open AI which we know how to do
that so I'm going to go and
Define the upload AI so we need a file
path okay and and I'm going to go ahead
and do that we've seen that before with
open and I'm going to find file pass the
file path and then say
RB and I'm going to say as file and I'm
going to say response in this
case I'm going to go get the client
files create and then pass the file
which is going to be just the file uh
that we have here we got here right and
then I'm going to get the path or read
actually because it's going to come in
in this case I want it to come in as
bytes okay stream really all
right and then of course I'm going to
pass the purpose going to be assistance
and what I want to happen for this
function is I want to return the actual
ID so I'm going to say response. ID so
this will return the ID of the file that
was uploaded very simple and next what
we'll do here we're going to create a
sidebar okay the
Side Bar say where users can upload
files so here I'm going to say file
upload I'm going to put that in a fun in
a so I'm going to put that in a variable
because we want access to that so file
upload and to generate a sidebar in
streamate again very very simple so we
just say St that's
sidebar tou and I'm going to say dot
file uploader because we want actually a
sidebar fly a sidebar with a file
uploader and we can pass some text to
say
upload a file to
be transformed into embeddings in a real
application obviously you probably don't
want to talk about embeddings because
most users won't even care but it's okay
we're here and then I need to pass here
a key just to say something file upload
and that's
that now we can also add a button that
says when click then they can actually
upload the file okay so this is going to
be just um the interface where they can
upload the file right drop the file and
then we need to allow them to click to
say actually want to upload the file
that we just dropped here upload file
button and we can also store the file ID
so I'm going to say if SD that's
sidebar as such I'm going to create a
button and this is going to be
upload file and you going to this will
make sense once you start seeing things
but I hope you're seeing the pieces
coming together I'm going to say if in
this case File uploaded this should be
file
uploaded
okay if there's something there if I
let's see
uploaded there we
go we got to go ahead and
open file uploaded in this case and get
the name and this should probably be F
string and we need to pass that we want
to say here we want
to write this as a binary that's why
we're going to say
uh
WB read write as binary RBS read as
binary as we saw earlier here okay and
all of that as F and I'm going to say F
that write going to write that file
uploaded okay and I'm going to say get
buffer and in this case here there are
times when also we want to allow users
to upload more than one files so I'm
going to just say something like maybe
another uh file
ID and I'm going to say
uploaded oh let's say upload I'm going
to call the upload to open
Ai and then put an F string here and
this I'm going to pass the file uploaded
and get the name as
such and let's make sure that we the we
take care of the session so the session
State file ID list let's see file _ id.
list doesn't give me intellisense that's
okay and I'm going to append let's see
file ID list sure I have that file ID
list file ID so this be file ID okay
there we
go and going to pend our another file ID
my such
and SD I'm going to create that sidebar
and write something to to it which is
going to be uh file
ID and then I'm going to pass the
another file ID as such so essentially
we're just writing on the wall on the
sidebar the ID of the other file ID that
was added so each time we added a file
and then we can see all those IDs okay
so what I want to do next is I want to
uh display
play those file
IDs so I'm going to make sure again look
at session State
file ID list if that's all good then I'm
going to go to
sidebar and write in this
case
uploaded file IDs so this is where we're
actually showing the thing things really
and then at the bottom we say
for file ID and S do that session I'll
make sure I get the
right list okay because it's going to be
a list with all those file
IDs that have potentially been
uploaded and I'm going to write into the
sidebar
again and I'm going to pass the file ID
now once we have these file IDs need to
associate them to the current assistant
that's very important because each
assistant can have multiple files okay
so how do we associate them so I'm going
to write here associate each file ID
with
the current assistant okay so I'm going
to say assistant file really and say
client beta and
assistants. files and I'm going going to
go ahead and create to create a file as
you know by now we need to pass the
assistant ID which we can get by say
assist ID right oops assist ID and then
we need the file ID which is going to be
file
ID that we have there okay so that's how
we associate that each file that we add
is going to be Associated to the correct
assistant
okay next we are going to go ahead and
SA button to
initiate the chat session okay we're
getting there okay so I'm going to put
in if state so you'll notice that in
streamlit to start in this case to
initiate something Handler right a
buttonclick handle Handler of of some
sort you say SD put an if sd.
sidebar. button
and I can
say start chatting and this is where we
handle the click okay so first we need
to make sure that uh all the files have
been uploaded that's very important so
that we can check that by saying STD go
to session State and then file
id id list okay make sure that we have
that session which means we have
something and then we're going to make
sure that our session state for start
chat in this case is going to be true
because that means we have everything
set up for things to be get going
because we've just clicked so that means
we have the file ID session which means
we have IDs that means then the session
for the start chat has to be true at
this point okay so now we're going to
create a
new thread we could create a new thread
can just go ahead and use that same
thread that's okay we're just going to
and create a new thread uh for this chat
session okay okay so again nothing new
you know how to create a thread so I'm
going to call this chat thread and so
I'm going to say client or yes client go
beta uh threads and create a thread okay
now we have the thread set the session
again of that thread this is very
important a lot of sessions here for the
reason I said so that's just how stream
lit works and uh session State and I'm
going to use the thread ID and I'm going
to pass the our chat thread. ID so now
we have set the session for this whole
thing the thread ID session to the
thread ID of this newly created
thread okay I'm going to write something
to the wall all right so so I'm going to
say thread
ID and I'm going to pass the
chat.
ID chat thread. ID notice that we inside
of this if statement here that handles
the on click and then else if none of
that is true I'm going to go ahead and
just say
something sd. side
r. warning right we can just invoke a
warning so the text is going to be
redish and I can just say something uh
no files
found please
upload a at
least one file to get
started all
right very good so we're making real
good progress here so one thing I want
you to keep in mind is that as we pass
this documents to the embeddings the
open eye embeddings so we are able to
attach all that information to enhance
as they call it the model so we can
converse or chat with it um whatever
comes when we ask a question whatever
comes the resulted response it also has
other metadata such as citations okay to
say okay this information that I got it
from this place in a document now we
have a very simple document but you can
imagine if you have a very large
document then this could be very helpful
and so what I'm going to do here just in
the interest of time I'm going to paste
in a helper function that will
essentially process message with
citations okay so it's very simple as
you see here extract content and
annotation from the message and format
citations as footnotes so it goes
through gets the content that we get for
as a response right and then that and go
goes through and looks for certain
annotation looks for certain attributes
in the message the whole payload uh
where we see annotations and if it sees
annotations of course it creates those
annotations goes through creates their
annotations and so forth so now there
are some limitations because we said
that we can pass different files right
which we will see but in this case here
um for retrieving decided files we're
going to do things uh we're going to use
some dumi way or dumi data to get that
going and I'm hardcoding here just is
for testing purposes I hope by the time
at some point once this assistance API
is mature we have ways to do certain
things such
as such as calling the cited files
details instead of us having to do all
this okay so but this is just to give
you some ideas now again this is not
perfect code um it just works for what
are we trying to do here to give you
some ideas okay so in this case here for
the file name cited file we are putting
in this case the cryptocurrency PDF
right hardcoded it again not a good idea
but that's what we're doing anyway okay
so that's what we're doing and then we
append we have the
citations list here and as all of that
is happening we retrieving all those
annotations and we're painting all of
them so that everything is set up okay
so that's what we do and after that we
create a
footnote in form of a a full response
and we get that information we put it
all together and then we'll return that
so that is essentially what we're doing
in this process message with citations
let's go ahead and continue putting
together the front end the API okay or I
should say the the page itself so I'm
going to say the so here is where I'm
going to put the main interface so we
can actually see
things okay so I'm going to use
streamlit again and I'm going to add a
title for our
page call it study
body now notice the difference here I'm
adding the title before we're adding the
title to the page configuration which is
those are two different things and if
you want to learn more about streamlit
which I encourage you to do we can just
Google real quick or stream lit and then
go to documentations it is the most
simplest straightforward way to create
prototype applications okay that's very
good in Python and I'm going to also St
stream L here I'm going to write
something here kind of like a subheader
and I can say learn fast by
chatting with your
documents okay good for marketing I
guess okay next we are going to again
check a few things check sessions
to make sure everything is good so we
can proceed so first we're going to
check that the chat is not already in
session so to do so we're going to say
if
St go to sessions that
chat oh
start
chat and if there is that session so if
there is a chat session that means
things have started so now I'm going to
go initialize them and this now we're
going to go ahead and and now we're
going to go ahead and initialize our
model so I'm going to say if open
AI
model not in
session okay I'm going to say
st. session
state. open
AI model I'm going to just say this is
going to be the chat GPT or
GPT 4 like that so we're using the
preview okay and that's the only thing
that actually works with what we're
trying to do if you try to do jpt 3
Turbo 3.5 turbo it's not going to
work and also I'm going to check
messages not in St session
state then I'm going to say s State
messages set that to empty so this is
going to help us of course with the bot
with the chat bot all right so let me go
ahead and show existing
messages if any so four
messages in
st.
session that messages
and I'm going to now invoke the chat
notice that this chat this is what I
talk about notice as I said we don't
have to do anything really when it comes
to creating a chat a chat box per se um
stream lit has that so I can say do chat
right it's part it's part of the
framework so I can go ahead and say chat
message all right look at that and I'm
going to pass the
message or
message in this case and get the
role this has to change to
message okay
singular and then we're going to go
ahead and add that and then we're going
to write the content inside of a
markdown okay so I'm going to say
message and get content of that
message okay so now we putting together
the actual chat and this will make a lot
of sense once we start running this and
apologize there's a lot of code but
believe me this is going to work well we
hope okay so now we're going to chat the
user so now we going to go ahead all
right now we're going to go ahead and
say chat input for the user so this is
where they're going to add something to
as a prompt so say if
prompt in this case s see that chat
prompt look at that we have chat input
as they call it that's the beauty of
streamlit I'm going to say what's new
that's going to be the first thing that
will see so what's
new all
right which will allow them to then add
user this so next I'm going to go ahead
add user message to the state and
display on the screen
so I'm going to put
session
messages and I'm going to pend in this
case I'm going to pass in as a
dictionary so first of all do
roll and
user okay it's going to be user for role
and then for the content that's where we
going to pass the actual
prompt we're going
to say chat messages or message
and this is we're going to show that
this is part where the user so we have
the user so this is the user chat
message and we're going to write that
using a mark down and we're going to
pass that prompt so now we're going to
go ahead and
add the
users message to the
existing
thread
how do we do that well we're going to
use client go better and go to threads
and messages and create that message and
how do we get or what is this me what we
need to create a message we need a
thread ID so we're going to go through
our session again because that's what's
driving
everything and go get and thread get a
thread ID and we need the role in this
case going to be
user and the content
is going to
be our
message oh actually it's going to be our
prompt right to create that message very
good okay we're getting there next we're
going to
create create and
run create a run with
additional
instructions okay so I'm going to say
run again nothing new here
beta threads runs and
create need to pass the thread ID so I'm
going to go go through the session State
again get a thread
ID and then assistant
ID we pass the assist
ID and then I'm going to pass
instructions I have the
instructions or
instructions and then let's pass the
instructions which I have here so please
answer the questions using the knowledge
provided in the files when adding
additional information make sure to
distinguish it with bold or underlying
text most us most likely they won't do
that but it's okay just to make sure we
can distinguish things
so next what I want to do is I want to
be able to show a spinner as all this
process is happening before we get the
actual response so that's good user
interface
addition so show a
spinner while the
assistant is
thinking okay okay so I'm going to say
with spinner so I stay
spinner and it's going to say wait
generating
response
such and then inside here I'm going to
put a while loop so I'm going to look at
the run right so status we could have
done we've done this differently before
but that's okay but we can just go
straight here status if it's
not
completed then we're going to sleep
for 1
second and then
run okay so can say run client
beta threads
runs and retrieve so we're going to
retrieve in this case our run so I'm
going to pass the thread ID which we
know we need to get from the
session session State and get the thread
ID and then pass the Run ID which we can
get that from just run.
ID okay and outside the while we are
going to then
retrieve
messages added by the
assistant okay I'm going to say message
or messages in this case I'm going say
client get to go to threads where that's
where all messages are and messages and
go to list and of course we need to pass
the thread ID go again to
session as such so now we have all the
messages and we can process all of that
I'm going to process and
display
assist
messages okay so I'm going to put
everything into inside of a list to make
things a little bit easier so I'm going
say
assistant
messages for run okay and I'm going to
pass the
message okay that's very
important and I'm going to pass a for
and then and then we're going to
actually pass a for Loop inside here
which is pretty cool for
messages or actually for say message
in okay say
message so we pass message first and
then on another index here we're going
to go do a for Loop so it's for
message
so so what we do here we have a message
and then
for message
in messages
so going to make sure that if
message that
run
ID is equal to run. ID and
message. roll is also equal to assistant
so essentially just making sure to put
all of the messages for our from our
assistant into this array so that way we
can then Loop through them so in this
case here I can say
and once we have that this list this
array list I can say for message I know
a lot of message here and then go to our
assistant messages for run because it is
indeed a list so we can Loop through it
um in this case here I'm going to just
say
full response and I'm going to say
process message with citation this is
where we're using that function that
helper function we created earlier or
just add it there and I'm going to pass
message it's going to be equal to
messages actually it's going to be equal
to message because we inside of a loop
so whatever are we getting
there and when that happens we are going
to also set the session
State
messages and append all those messages
in so in this
case going to create a dictionary here
so so for the
role it's going to be
assistant and again for
Content we going to pass the full
response so create a dictionary to add
into our
messages
State okay and then here I'm going to go
ahead and get the chat message because
we need now to use that which is going
to be the
assistant and then we're going to add
that all those responses onto the screen
so I'm going to use mark down again and
pass the full response and I'm going to
also pass the unsafe allow to True okay
and say all out to true for HTML so if
you have over um let's go mark down here
this will you can scroll down and see
that the unsafe allow bullan by default
any HTML tags found in body will be
escaped and therefore treated as pure
attack this Behavior may be turned off
by setting this argument to true all
right okay so it's hard to show you
everything but we are inside of if in
this case to make sure that we chat
input for the user so I'm going to come
down here go to that level I'm going to
say else if none of this is actually
happening that means we can
prompt use users to start chat so we
just say
St and say write we can just write
something and say please upload at least
a file to get
started by clicking on the
button say on
the
start
chat button and
such all right there's a lot of things
here but that's okay should be all good
okay again remember you will have access
to this code so it's not a big deal so
essentially we are creating this chat
and there's a lot of sessions going on
here but that's important like I said
because with streamlit you have to make
sure that the sessions are all set up
because streamlet whenever you click a
button it refreshes the entire page and
that means you start from scratch so you
lose all the state so we want to make
sure we have the state that's why we
have all this state thing going on here
want to learn more about that you can
check out their documentations okay so
we should have everything set up for us
um let's see if this works let me go
ahead
and um make sure that we can say
stream stream lit run and make sure
we're running the main not the app that
Pi or
py in
enter and you can see we have this very
nice usern interface that was created
which we can go ahead and use so for now
let's see if this works I'm going to go
to browse and then I'm going to go ahead
and get the crypto currency again and
there we go we have this cryptocurrency
it's there now we're going to go ahead
and say
upload it's uploading and voila so that
file was indeed uploaded file ID
uploaded file ID is there very good so
is it true if we go back to if we go to
open Ai and let's go
refresh and we can actually look at the
files we should hopefully see
cryptocurrency one of these files I
added a little bit ago is going to show
us exactly uh the the purpose status is
ready and how the size of it and of
course also the file ID okay we have two
there but that's okay now let's go back
to the application and let's start
chatting so click Start chat and what's
up I'm going to say tell me
about data
mining let's go ahead and see what's
going to happen so voila you can see the
weight generating response is working
and then we have this all this was given
to us uh by streamlet that's really if
we had to build all of that ourselves
that would be pretty um would take us a
long time okay so now it's going to look
at the cryptocurrency and look at it and
make sure that it gets the information
that it needs it appears that there may
be some confusion around the term data
mining it is it pertains to
cryptocurrency which the uploaded files
seem to disguise aha this is good
because it's saying the uploaded files
seems to disguise so he looking at those
two files that one I uploaded before and
that's okay usually you should probably
just get one there uh but also it's
probably from the previous upload that
we did when we first ran this it's okay
so in this case they're mining in the
context of cryptocurrencies usually
refers to the process of mining
cryptocurrencies themselves and blah
blah blah and there we go so uh we can
say can you tell
me how
many crypto
currencies are the are discussed are
being
discussed in the
document hit enter and voila there we
go okay there we go apologize in
convenience but seems there is an issue
accepting the content document title
Cryptor PDF the page has had no contents
uh when I tried to open it which means
means I cannot determine how many C okay
all right that's okay uh what I can do
again remember this is still in beta
sometimes happens so what I can do let
me see if I can delete one of these
perhaps maybe that's going to uh it
shouldn't that shouldn't be a thing
anyway but sometimes this happens and
sometimes it does weird stuff so it's
okay we're just going to try again maybe
this time it will
work okay so now it worked say based on
the search results document mentions
several cryptocurrencies including
Bitcoin Litecoin I think that's what it
called
ether and potential others are not named
explicitly and blah blah blah that's
really good I can also ask now the other
thing also I can go ahead and upload a
different file or another file okay so
I'm going to say upload oh shoot so this
is a problem now that I uploaded I
uploaded two files so if I refresh this
this is exactly what I didn't want to do
I should have
this
file just delete a few here and it's
very strange because it
shows all of these different files have
been uploaded let me just delete some of
them some of them says upload others
says uploaded I'm not sure why but okay
let's go ahead and delete some of them
and go
back go back here and I'm going to
browse to go get yet another one so I
have another one called lipids this is
is a biology
file and that's the one I'm going to go
ahead and upload try again this
sometimes doesn't work let me upload
that
one okay that file was uploaded and
let's see if I can upload another one
issue because we have that let's upload
this
one okay so now we have two files that
were uploaded let's go back to opening I
and I'm going to refresh
here
okay so we have a few files that were
uploaded but one thing I can do I can go
to assistant so I think this will be
better and go
here and I can see the files that were
uploaded wow there's a lot of files that
were uploaded so it looks like when you
first upload something they change their
names from upload first and then they
the IDS are created I think that's
what's happening I'm not sure it's very
strange so it's a little bit buggy but
it's okay so uh let's see if this works
so now we're going to ahead and start
chatting okay let's talk about because
we have two files let me go ahead and
talk about biology I'm going say what is
a
lipid okay so now it should be able to
go and fetch the file in this case the
lipid the biology file that has
information about lipids and so forth
hopefully all right this worked so
lipids are biological molecules that
have limited solubility in water and are
soluble in nonpolar organic solvents
okay so this is really good because it
went and got the information from the
document because we have even the source
and everything here that is showing very
good so I can also go back and ask about
this case um
cryptocurrency what is
crypto
okay so what comes here with four
resources crypto such as Bitcoin litcoin
and all this stuff and explains
everything and very awesome okay so this
is actually working which is very
exciting now remember these are just
examples that I assembled really to
Showcase how to use assistance API and
so that you can take this to the next
level okay so this is no production code
obviously for many reasons but at least
gives you some ideas the other thing
also to remember is that the assistance
API is still in beta which means they're
still working on it and maybe some apis
will change by the time you're watching
this but I hope you understand at least
what's happening the basics of how
assistance API work I give you a little
bit the rundown of the vector store
embedding so how things work in the
background and how assistance API in so
many ways allow us developers to really
not think too much about what's in the
background which is really exciting but
also I need to let you know that with
that we get a lot of some disadvantages
meaning that we don't have a lot of
control but with all of that flexibility
all of that abstraction we also lose a
few things one of the things you will
notice even though assist is API it's
most likely going to get keep getting
better um it's important to also know
that there are other tools that you can
use that perhaps give you a little bit
more flexibility ability but also that
means that you have to do a little bit
more work per se not too much uh there's
this tool called Lang chain which I'm
just going to let you know about it's a
wonderful framework that allows you to
really assemble many other many other
models in this case many other large
language models because there's not just
um opening eye chat gbts and gpts there
are many others as well for this
framework you are able to actually see
most of the things we talked about most
of the things that open a I have
abstracted things out for us which is a
good thing but you're able to see or be
able to do more in the backand in terms
of choosing your own Vector stores
indexing all your documents so the
process that I showed you in the back
end that's happening um you will
actually be able to see more it becomes
more apparent if I may say that all
right so that is a different topic but
just something to keep in mind and I
hope this course has given you something
at least to think about some good
starting points when it comes to the
assist and API and you can keep learning
of course watching for the documentation
because things will change that's just a
known um fact and so but I hope this
course was able to give you the tools
that you need to at least start thinking
about how to use the assistance API to
build all sort of things and now we
didn't touch on the on using the code
interpreter as a tool directly really
but that's something you can do as an
exercise so you can create a bot or you
can create a tool that will analyze code
in fact I think we talked a little bit
as an exercise earlier but now you have
the tools you know stream lit or at
least you have some ideas you can use
that to create a code body something
like this right or a uh pair programming
buddy or something like that that will
help you debug things and go from there
right so a lot of things that you can do
here a lot lot of things but I've just
scratched the surface and I hope you
enjoy this course I hope you like this
style that I use to to teach this course
and I hope this was useful thank you so
much for your time and I'll see you
next